could you be sure to have a microphone
um
near nearby you're a little
soft
[Music]
representative mcguire and i will share
this
oh yes yes
as the subcommittee chairman of the
house e-dna committee regarding
part seven and senate bill
on the senate bill 133
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the covalent epidemic and in
excuse me representative
it's difficult to hear you your voice is
very soft
i mean i know the words because i've
heard them before but otherwise i might
not understand you
sorry
let's try again this is a public hearing
on bills referred to the committee and
scheduled in the house calendar for
today the question before the house is
sounds good
thank you
an executive session may uh will not be
held today
uh please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
but wait there's more
all members of this committee and select
legislative staff and interested members
of the public have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting through the zoom electronic
meeting platform and the public has
access to contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all necessary access
information has been made available in
the house calendar and through the
electronic calendar on the general court
website the notice for this meeting
complies with the house rules and rsa
91a
anyone who has a problem accessing this
meeting call 271 3600
or email
hcs
[Music]
the normal extension
in the event that the public is unable
to access the meeting that's too bad the
meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled please note
that all votes that are taken during
this meeting shall be done by roll call
vote
uh let's start the meeting by quote
taking a roll call attendance of the sub
committee
uh remember each member when i call your
name please state your presence and
where you are whether anyone is with you
in the room
uh during the meeting which is required
under the right to not know for
inexplicable reasons
part of the editorialism
okay the subcommittee is representative
mcguire president of the committee room
that's a very interesting question i'm
not sure
uh we do have other members of committee
presence representative
uh it's fine with me because as they
said we are not taking a vote but we i
would like to achieve consensus if
that's possible
to the extent that that's possible i
think we can i think
the reason we're not taking about is
that we don't have a final amendment and
that we will need a
complete amendment for senate bill 133
but if we agree on what this section of
the amendment want to say it'll make
pam's job in stitching the pieces
together
i have a question for representative
there had been some emails and
one of them
uh
contains the latest a version a late
version of the
changes made by
oplc to section 7. do you do you have
that
i didn't email it to you i'm happy to
suspend for a minute and
email to people
i have a copy mr chair you have a copy
okay
i do not have a copy mr chair
but i'm happy to participate
okay representative schmidt i will go
through the changes so that
uh
i
i don't think you'll actually need it
because they're very easy to understand
they're very good i i accept that as an
alternative okay representative schuett
you i i think you were i interrupted you
that's okay thank you i um i did not
uh look for that didn't know to
so i have not seen it
well you represent
being here represents an unexpected
pleasure but as i said to representative
schmidt
i think what i'm about to say will be
um
easy to understand and non-controversial
as a matter of fact
it's what we had uh had agreed
had requested at our first subcommittee
meeting
it's
it's pretty clear we're going to need
another uh subcommittee meeting and i'll
you'll see why in a minute
um
first
let me go through the changes that oplc
made and then imprise you of some
late-breaking helpful developments
um
but let's do one thing at a time
the
um
they
mr porter and
going looking at part seven
section two you've inserted the uh
standing orders
is that correct that i i i'm just not
familiar enough
part seven section two yep um um hold on
just a second
for the benefit of representative
schuett and schmidt why don't you please
explain what you have put in here
because it's technical but they i want
them to understand
sure and um just for clarity would you
like me to go through all the changes
the changes as requested by the
subcommittee
last meeting plus what we've added or
i want you uh first that's uh a
wonderful suggestion i wish i had
thought of it
yes except for the very last two
that you inserted with word i'll i'll
talk about them separately okay
so first um
if
on of the word document well part seven
we added in a new section two on
standing orders to amend our general
statute 310 a1d
to insert a new subsection saying all
board councils and commissions may issue
standing orders delegating
non-discretionary tasks to staff at the
oplc
the reason for this actually came about
due to a
ongoing
audit of the dental board and i'm not
sure how much detail i can give here but
um
just by way of background
some of our boards or many of our boards
have um issued
standing orders to
allow staff
to
issue um
licenses if they if if certain criteria
are met
in between meetings and so
if it if uh
applic if a profession requires is their
licensure
um just
uh
i don't know what to say to say a list
of non-discretionary things um like you
need to have graduated from an
accredited school in dental
and you need to pay the fee and
you need to submit your resume
if those criteria are met the boards
have um
issued a standing order saying staff may
um
give a license to the individual in
between a board meeting so that those
that individual doesn't need to wait
another 30 days to get their license
for the board to review the application
um
and then there's a carve out that says
if anything um
if any of the following are found on the
application
um
the administrator forwards this to the
board and it gets reviewed at the next
board meeting and we lay out there uh if
the person has a criminal record if they
have any
um
uh
any
action taken by a board in another state
really the board can set the parameters
there um
so
we have had some boards do this uh at a
recent recent audit the dental or the
dental board audit the lba auditor
suggested that the board may not have
the authority to do that and had
suggested that if they wanted to do that
they may need to say seek um legislative
change so
we threw this in where we we
thoughtfully put this i should say um
because we found that that's very
helpful the boards um like it it lets
people get license quicker
and just notice it it still is up to the
board it's that the board may issue the
standing order we have some boards that
have said we want to keep seeing all the
applications um
but uh
it is something that has been helpful i
think
both administratively and to the public
um
mr broderick before i uh comment on that
i i have a question but i want to
welcome representative o'brien and i
reckon i know that representative
schmidt has his hand up and we'll get to
that in a second
thank you mr chair
let me make absolutely clear this has
nothing to do with policy this has to do
with are the boxes checked
and the may
issue the standing orders implies that
they may revoke the standing orders
correct um so to your first point we
have some boards that require
for their initial license some
subjective requirements so actually an
example is uh psychology i see dr warner
is here
psychology has um
essay questions that need to be well not
graded need to be reviewed by the board
so for psychology they really can't do
this specific standing order at this
time
but other boards
yeah it's uh
checking the box do they have this
education have they paid the fee um
and if those
requirements are met
by checking the box i mean there's no um
this is i'm i'm emphasizing it's
non-discretionary this is they jump
through the hoop or not
correct yep now you mentioned in what
you just said
that there was a carve out and i don't
see that in section two where is this
carve out that you said
that they could wait till the next
meeting whatever um well
the carve out is in the way we draft up
the standing orders so
um i actually have one if the committee
would like to see a
an example i have one up because i was
just discussing this with a different
board um
but we draft them
like this specific standing order we
draft to say
um
here are
where the board
can issu the board can issue the license
if if the general requirements are met
but if the application
contains any of the following
um
the administrator hangs on to that
application and brings it to the next
board meeting and so i meant that's what
i meant to the carve out so it will say
if the application shows that they have
any criminal record it gets
um it gets brought to the board's next
meeting if the person has a record from
any other
jurisdiction a board in any other
jurisdiction it gets brought to the next
board meeting
um and it really allows the board to um
the exact constraints of when they want
to see it and when they're okay with the
administrator
um
issuing it so the short take is that if
all the boxes cannot be checked it's got
to be kicked back and that's part of the
standing order correct okay
uh representative schmidt
thank you mr chairman and i will turn on
my camera
so tom when you began you said may issue
and i'm wondering uh
whether there's any distinction between
i mean are we talking about renewal of
licenses only or are we talking about
people as well who might be brand new
because you mentioned several things
that uh that one would
assume have would not be uh applicable
for
renewals
that in that criminal background
issues and so forth uh obviously
somebody can get in trouble even if
they're already licensed but so are we
talking about
anybody or just renewals here
so the the wording we proposed in in
what is in front of the subcommittee is
broad and would allow any um
non-discretionary matter to be um
to be in a standing order delegated to
the board's administrator
and so a board could choose to say
just initial applications
this standing order only applies to
initial applications or the standing
order only applies to renewals
the
the boards that have implemented this
process
uh i believe they all say for initial
licenses for renewals and for
reinstatements
um
okay that that it was just uncertain in
my mind i and uh by good morning by the
way thank you so
okay thank you mr chair
representative schmidt we're glad to
hear your good for the moment there will
be more moments
i'm sure
uh please go on tom
um
so the next change in what we had sent
over is to
let's see they're on page one so it's
part seven the original section two i
did not go through and renumber the
sections
um so 310 a1h1
this was requested by the subcommittee
we deleted that in consultation with and
we added in when requested by so instead
of saying in consultation
with the board the
office shall assign an investigator it
says when requested by the board the
office yeah hold on a second that it was
not that wasn't what we had talked about
as i recall that's something uh
that's one of the later
changes no that's something we talked
we wanted to make sure that
it was obvious
and clear that it was the board deciding
that they wanted an investigator from
the office rather than some other
process
and that's what that was what that
language was
was to address so okay uh but uh and the
subcommittee doesn't know this there is
a
in your word
a subcommittee understand you don't see
this yet i'll get to it uh you had a an
additional change and i'm confusing that
i'm not sure the distinction between the
additional change and the change we
requested
yes and i actually don't have that
document to open up but i can if you
want to go through that because
i'll tell you what that's not what i
want to talk about at the moment but
let's look at this
you have the wording when in the court
uh
you have eliminated in consultation with
and replaced it with when requested by
the board the office shall assign an
investigator comma
uh
that is hanging and i think it needs
something
it's going to need some polishing up
like this while suggests something like
this
when requested by the board and to the
extent exten requested by the board the
office shall assign an investigator who
may assist in the investigation
does that sound all right to you
i'm looking mostly for uh the fact that
i'm okay with that uh
mike is our um
is an enforcement unit so i just want to
make sure he has the opportunity to
chime in
all right good morning mike speak please
good morning everybody thank you so i i
think instead of the comma i think that
was supposed to be just a period and a
hard stop um and i think the intent of
it was
um to clearly leave the designation by
the board that if they request it that
we shall provide it um and i think that
it was instead of a comma it just should
be a period with a hard stop
okay do you have any object i
even with a hard stop it seems to be
kind of a
slightly awkward sense do you have any
objection to the wording that i proposed
nope i i think it still meets i
absolutely still think it meets the
intent so no i don't
okay great thank you uh all right having
so subcommittee uh you've heard uh
you've heard the gist of what we've
talked about this is mostly
what i view about 99 100 grammar
style
please go on tom
sure um
directly under that i added a new
provision
1a
and this was i think the main concern of
the subcommittee
stating the procedures set forth in 310
a1h through 310 a1l are supplementary
and shall not supplant or supersede any
procedures expressly set forth in any
board's individual practice act
i think that was the the main issue that
i agree with that mr chair and that was
one of the issues i had brought up that
i had trouble with and i'm glad to see
uh okay tom
proceed please sure thing and i'm my son
just got up so you might hear him in the
background i can go upstairs if i need
to
so
the the bottom of that same page
subsection 4 of 310 a1h
um
here was where the subcommittee wanted
some clarification on um when a board
can disclose information to law
enforcement and health licensing
agencies
um
so i added in
may disclose information acquired in an
investigation to law enforcement if it
involves suspected criminal activity
and that's all i added and then it goes
on to help licensing agencies in this
state or any other jurisdiction
or in response to specific statutory
i think that meets the sub i know that
meets the subcommittee's object or
concern unless the subcommittee or
other members of our committee have
something to say i'd like to ask time to
move on
okay
no hands
look mom no hands no
next uh next please um the next one was
very minor the next top and next page
subsection six it used to say the board
may dismiss a complaint it now says each
board made us
miss a complaint and i believe this was
to uh representative goalie's concern
just for clarity
uh i think you're right and you said
um
next one is section
7 below
um
and if you could
just give me one minute my son is
downstairs now so i want to move
somewhere with less noise
um
subsection seven dealt with uh
when the board can take non-disciplinary
well
that the
individual
tom can you you froze up there for a
second and your speech was blocked as
well can you repeat the last second
if i may mr chair
before we move on all right go ahead
represent goalie
i think i'll just go back briefly tom on
six
roman 06 the each board that we changed
to each board
i just have a quick question because
underneath it the way the boards are
defined and that's what i
explained was i thought was different is
it says boards
which shall include all boards councils
and commissions
and that was the language i was looking
for i don't know if that is just a
technical change or if it if we're okay
with
do you see what i'm talking about if you
look right below that
i think do so it was drafted um
that each
all right
uh the beginning of section two
you'll see 310 it this is creating a new
chapter 310 a1h
and subsection 1 begins by saying boards
which shall include all boards councils
and commissions
so
um and and the
provision we had talked about that we
changed each board
is in that
chapter or in that
subsection in 310 a1h
and so
my read of it is that in subsection one
we're defining boards broadly is all
boards councils and commissions
and then in subsection six we're saying
each board which means
each
all boards councils and commissions
um
so
that's
why i changed it to just this but i'm
happy to further work on that if need be
i was just wondering if it should stay
consistent in wording throughout the
i think you can achieve that
consistency by capitalizing the b
um
actually i tend to agree with tom that
in this section you define boards once
and then all the rest of the language
except in paragraph four
it says the office or the board's
councils and commissions
and that's what i'm sit going along with
then you might as well stick the uh
council's commissions and so forth into
all right i'm happy to do that
so much
so subsection seven uh
this i would change to add upon making
an affirmative finding and then i added
after notice and an opportunity for
hearing the board counsel or commission
may take non-disciplinary remedial
action
and this was to um
the subcommittee was concerned that it
wasn't didn't clearly state that they
have an opportunity for a hearing if the
board's going to take this action so we
okay seeing no
objections or
questions please proceed
all right and then
the next change that you'll see in front
of you is
um i added in a subsection eight
um
directly underneath that says
all proceedings for non-disciplinary
remedial action shall be exempt from the
provisions of rsa 91a
except that the board may disclose any
final remedial action that affects the
status of a license including any
non-disciplinary restrictions imposed
so um
to explain this this was not something
that the subcommittee had
uh requested
when i went through this again
um
i believed this was missing uh
so the
the only board right now that has this
um
this option to take non-disciplinary
remedial action is the board of medicine
and i believe they found it helpful uh
if
if someone is does not have the mental
capacity temporarily or or permanently
to practice anymore they can take
as you can imagine any hearing on those
matters would contain a lot of sensitive
um
medical psychological information
and so the board of medicine statute
has this provisions basically saying the
hearing's closed to the public um
any full order would be closed to the
public
um however the board will make public
that
uh like the disciplinary or the
actions the restrictions that the board
put on the license um
i
thought we had missed putting that in
sounds good to me yeah
subcommittee the idea is the
non-disciplinary part of keeping this
confidential for the reasons tom said
this
makes sense
i agree
thank you representative o'brien uh
well let's let's move on and if anybody
has an objection i will listen or
concern uh
please proceed tom
sure the next change um was a very
simple one on page four
subsection three of 310 a1k
there was just a typo it had said
sections um
prior to imposing any sections i changed
that to sanctions
i don't think there will be any concerns
about that
and that that was it in what i
originally had sent to the board
or to the subcommittee i'm sorry
okay uh i think the subcommittee has
heard that and i'd like to bring up what
uh
some helpful developments there have
been some reason like within the past 48
hours developments that
i have not really been privy to i've
just learned about them myself
and they were i believe instituted or
discovered by
dr warner
and i'm going to ask tom to comment on
those they fall into two categories
one are
[Music]
helpful
elimination of redundancies or
clarifications
the other is has to do with uh from what
i understand and i don't know this
has to do with disciplinary
uh
her suggestions she made with respect to
the disciplinary
procedure
now in the course of that
it became clear that the
border psychologists and
psychology
and the medical board have different med
have different disciplinary proceedings
oplc has no issue
with the substance of
the
um
how a disciplinary hearing is done but
it does have a concern about
it's the general desire of keeping all
of the disciplinary proceedings as
uniform as possible to promote
efficiency and consistency
so
i would like tom first to discuss the
ones that i'll call that are
basically uh
that are the cleanup
sure thing and um
just
to add to that explanation after i had
sent the subcommittee our draft on
monday or friday
i don't remember when i sent my copy
doctor i had provided it to dr warner
and she helpfully provided some feedback
as well so some of the changes she had
provided to us we had disagreed with um
respectfully but um
she did helpfully find out
two or three other issues
and they're all
fairly minor um
but they're important so
again going back to page one so
uh
310a1h1 this is related to the other
change um
the
we had changed it from in consultation
with
with the board the office shall assign
an investigator
we'd change it to when requested by the
board the office shelter inside an
investigator it originally had continued
who shall complete the investigation in
accordance with rules adopted by the
executive director
um
uh dr warner helpfully pointed out that
with the
change to state that
these procedures are supplementary
and don't supplant individual boards
procedures
it's no longer correct to say that
if an investigator is appointed they
need to follow
the
rules adopted by the executive director
so
we're proposing we can just eliminate
that last clause and i understand
representative scitec that you would
like um some additional language to sort
of finish off that clause
okay
and
what i did early in our first you may
recall i conflated the fact that there
were two changes made here one we
requested as a subcommittee the other
pointed out by uh dr warner but they
were you we've addressed them both at
this point
correct correct okay
uh
the next uh
next change please
sure the the next change uh that dr
warner had pointed out is on page well
involves page two and page three so
subsection four on page two that's three
ten a one i subsection 4
and
top of page 3 310a1j1
so the first section began by saying
disciplinary proceedings shall be opened
to the public then it continues final
board actions
um
it goes on but it says disciplinary
proceedings shall be opened at the
public
if you scroll down 310 a1j
one
begins by saying disciplinary
proceedings shall be opened to the
public comma except upon order by the
board counsel or commission upon good
cause shown
so
my recommendation to deal with this
confliction is to
get rid of the first sentence um that
simply says dislike disciplinary
proceedings shall be open to the public
um
the more specific one should stand which
allows the board
in limited circumstances to close
a hearing or portions of the hearing
to the public
and again the same concerns if there's
highly confidential medical information
that must be discussed as part of the
hearing um
it
i i think it really should be non-public
so which
so which section are you
would you be deleting the part
that talks about the
final actions and so forth
i i would recommend deleting the first
sentence of that section so the first
sentence of three ton a1i subsection 4
which is on page 2.
thank you the sentence disciplinary
proceedings shall be open to the public
and representative goal you notice that
it said by order of the board council or
okay uh the next uh change please
sure there was only one more and this
was actually one i caught
oh um
so when we went through this before i
had mentioned that i added in the
provision to make non-disciplinary
remedial actions exempt from disclosure
under 91a
and i had said i had added it in because
i did not see it in the draft
i was wrong it it does occur in the
draft on page
what is it page 3 310 a1j
um
subsection six had the same exact
language um
as what i had added in
however i i believe it makes more sense
up where i added it in um because it's
with the section on non-disciplinary
remedial action
um
so my suggestion is to delete it from
310 a1j
and essentially move it up to the new
section i had created
okay this is is i guess more
organization of the statute than
anything
dr warner
uh yes thank you i i had raised my hand
on the other item about
uh the conflict between those two things
about having the hearing made public
and i just wanted to point out that
eliminating the general one and going to
the more specific one is very helpful
and allows the board to close a portion
of the meeting for good cause and that
will make it consistent with
for example the privacy
statute language change that was made
several years ago
that if
uh
a patient is subpoenaed to testify at a
hearing
and they
would like that to be
shielded from the public that they can
and and so this helps
reflect that
great um
if i hear uh no
uh concerns or objections by the
subcommittee i'd like to speak with hope
do i see ahead
uh
i will uh speak with oplc
after this or just to be sure that we're
we have these changes so that the
subcommittee can vote
an amendment on section 7. but that
brings me to the last issue
which is substantive
it's come to my attention in the course
of this last few hours of the past 48
hours
that the disciplinary
procedure
for the board of psychology is different
than the disciplinary
procedure for say the other boards
in particular the board of medicine
and
my instinct is the whole point of what
we've been doing lately is that unless
there is good reason shown
the disciplinary hearings should be the
same
and
i would like to either
make the disciplinary hearings for
procedure
for the board of psychology agree or be
the same as consistent with the board of
medicine or the other way i'm not sure
why we have two on the screen
and
that is represents a substantive change
which i can undertake on my own and have
an amendment
a separate amendment
but i want to alert the subcommittee
that that is an issue
or could be an issue now the
subcommittee can choose to
i want to hear from dr warner because i
expect that she'll object to my concern
and i'm willing to listen to reason but
i do listen to reason
but i
um
like
to have that
resolved now whether
it is worth the trouble at this point is
a question for the subcommittee or the
full committee to decide
uh we have right now if i don't say
another word a fine document on section
get into uh
good form for our vote
at our next subcommittee meeting got to
figure out when that will be by the way
so having said that
i'd like to hear from
dr warner i guess why the
why the
board of psychology cannot use the board
of medicine's disciplinary procedure
if she's not if
if she's ready if you're ready to
discuss that i realize i'm springing
this on you sure
so sure i i'm always ready to discuss
that
okay go ahead please that's just fine um
thank you for asking i appreciate it
very much i i think that the board of
psychology has done a lot of work
on their procedures probably more so
than many of the other boards
and so
we're we've refined it greatly i think
that the board of medicine could could
perhaps adopt some of our
more advanced procedures but then again
they are a much larger profession and
some of those things might not be
might be workable or feasible for them
i think that
certainly for the sanity of the oplc
attorneys and the process
a consistency is highly desirable
and i think it would be a nice goal
perhaps one might put together like a
two-year
uh study in addition outside of this
whole omnibus bill but a study to look
at what are the the better parts of all
the various boards and see if they could
be um
brought together into some sort of
amalgamation
that would be fruitful for the sanity of
oplc as well as the good jurisdiction of
these boards but there are things like
the privacy statute that um several of
you are very very familiar with you said
representative scitec representative
mcguire representative schmidt and
others
were very involved in
that privacy matter and and we were
helping representative neil kirk and i
had certainly hoped that after practice
and in the
boards of mental health practice and
board of psychologists that those
procedures could be refined a little bit
and perhaps promulgated to the other
boards there are things like that as
well as our uh our own and the board of
mental health two-step process in terms
of allegation and then complaint that is
very very good for
both protecting the public as well as
being fair to the professions
the board of medicine has something
slightly similar i believe where they do
some mediation before it goes before
review
but these things
there's many many fine points to this
that i think should be
very much closely examined and
especially with the commission perhaps
with representatives from these
different boards or people who are no um
that are familiar with these processes
that could examine this
in detail
and also obviously lplc involved so that
they can say what they think will be
reasonable for them to do
so that's what i would suggest for your
desire to bring consistency i'm not
against consistency
but there's a lot of
cumbersome things to deal with in that
i'm going to ask
for oplc's comments but let's recognize
representative schuett first
thank you mr chair um
i do have an appreciation for the need
for
privacy for particularly as dr warner
suggested
patients who are testifying in any of
these
fields there's always
um the concern with
hypoplations etc for what's divulged
uh i'm a little saddened to not see
representatives of the other board that
are being mentioned
uh prepped for input this morning i
think that
might be helpful
i would add also i i believe that
as large as this overhaul
of
oplc is
i think we can probably all agree that
there will probably need to be
some tweaks going forward after this is
enacted
and i'm wondering if it would be useful
if it's necessary for us to give
permission or if it's just something
that oplc could foster
to have
instead of a commission just perhaps
casual meetings of
representatives of each of the
medical field boards particularly get
together and
talk about where they could come to
agreement
on these kinds of subjects
thank you representative schuett i would
i think you're absolutely right but the
the section that we left in saying
disciplinary proceedings shall be open
to the public
except upon order of the board etc upon
good cause shown
i think protecting the privacy of a
okay
okay but the general question about
which representative should brought up
brings up
is whether
we
in by implication whether we need to
address that today or whether
consistent with what dr warner has said
this is a larger picture and maybe we
want to look at various medical boards
and
dental nurse uh
the met board of medicine itself and try
to
re-examine either on local i guess
oplc's own to suggest possible tweaks as
representative schuett described them
so i think we're probably going to leave
this battle for another day
although it's i think it's worth
spending the time one time to try to get
them get the procedures a uniform
procedure because i still i don't see
much difference any difference between
how the board of medicine may approach a
complaint as opposed to the board of
psychology let's get the best of each
both worlds
okay
thank you mr chairman so i think this
issue of privacy is uh really central to
uh
our deliberations and i was troubled at
first when i said that when i heard that
um
you know that proceedings are going to
be open to the public
because
the one thing that
differentiates us most from other
creatures on the planet is
what
sometimes is called spirit or mind uh
but is
absolutely central and to the degree
that
uh you've got a bad knee or a shoulder
or whatever uh if you're
an athlete and and bad shoulder puts you
out of action
that's
it's unfortunate but that's not the kind
of thing
that is so important but to the degree
that somebody and that's why the board
of psychiatry is special uh and so i
think that the privacy of people uh and
not only if they're testifying but
perhaps
the complaint would involve something
that doesn't involve testimony of the of
the
the patient of the individual the client
but
but involves a discussion of how the
practitioner
may have
sinned if you will against that person
and where their private
matters would come under discussion that
absolutely cannot be
uh open to the public so uh i think we
have to have language it makes it clear
and i'm okay with the psychiatrist and
the psycho psychiatry being a special
case
it is the board of psychology
oh sorry so i i'm so
psychology thank you for correcting that
mr chair you and i can talk about that
if this when that day ever dawns but i
think medical issues such as getting uh
whether you have an std is something
that is a little different than a sore
shoulder so i think
there are issues out there but the
privacy aspect is is especially crucial
with uh
um i think the board of psychology and
if there were a box up there that had
somebody from the medical profession
they might say the same thing but let's
leave that battle for another day i
agreed to that too mr chairman
i have a suggestion
perhaps we could extend
would
something like good cause shall include
the private information of individuals
other than the licensing
because
the licensee's private information is
something that's a matter of discipline
but
but the
individuals other than the licensees
should not be
right
i think that i think the chair's
observation that we're going to save it
for another day gives us the opportunity
to ruminate about this whole complex and
come up with alternatives for for that
other day
it isn't that i disagree with
representative mcguire it's just i
haven't had a chance to think about it
and
i think it's a part of the bigger
picture i realize that sounds like
kicking the cam can down the road and it
is but it's being done in good faith
that i'd like to try to get the best of
uh
such as it may be uh things may well
let's that's that's for another day uh
mr porter mike europe
i uh thank you very much so um i wanted
to go back to something representative
schuett mentioned which is um
rather than a study and and i couldn't
agree more and so something i want to
let the subcommittee
know is part of my job as the
enforcement administrator is kind of
like being an ambassador to all the
boards where we are meeting with each
board individually and there's 55 total
so it's going to take a while but
um
we are flushing out processes that work
versus processes that don't work and i
think
one of the central issues that i think i
know i mentioned in the very very
beginning uh a couple weeks ago was
the balance of the public health safety
and welfare with the due process rights
of the licensee and when we talk about
public health safety and welfare
we also
really need to include
for the disciplinary portion the privacy
of third parties and i know i've had
these conversations with dr warner
about you know when to subpoena records
who's authorized um but more importantly
some of the
trends unfortunately that we've been
seeing here in enforcement involve um
sexual assault allegations
and those can be um career enders for
the licensee but it can also be
um
very difficult for the alleged victim
and we do have victims who are victims
of sexual assault and i think having
these privacy issues uh having having
those closed off during a hearing this
isn't criminal court um this is
administrative and i think that it is
something we are having conversations
with each board about so
um i really want to thank representative
schuett for for address talking about
that
we are engaged in that and we can we
will continue to engage
next week i think i have three board
meetings where we'll be discussing these
so mr porter do i take from this that as
time goes by
you will be examining
the disciplinary proceedings for the
various boards and doing some of this on
your or making suggestions
uh on your own
i came at it just from the consistency
of the two boards psychology and medical
it may be a bigger picture than that
and
i
i would look forward to seeing
a uniform procedure among the
medical professions uh
with exceptions as as appropriate
so is that fair to expect this for the
next few years
very fair and and i definitely want to
say that um
you know like the medical board i'm
working closely with the mrsc as well as
the board of medicine
um and
our ultimate goal with this bill is
exactly what you just mentioned
consistency and efficiency across all
boards because that actually helps the
general public as well
mike thank you and if schmidt and i get
reelected when this gets done let us
i was i was going to ask the same thing
but
then
at this point i think we're going to
leave that big picture as part of the
big picture i'm going to ask
for oplc to continue its fine
really great work you did in um
buffing
not buffing it up uh
changing this
on section seven in accordance with what
you've heard from the subcommittee i
will
ask that
when requested by the board the office
shall inside an investigator full stop
be changed to something like when
requested by the board and to the extent
uh requested by the board the office
shall sign an investigator who may
assist in the investigation
i don't think i think that just smoother
and keeps
clear
that the
board is
right mike right tom
correct yes
i'm sorry about that yes i i
i like to listen to reason even if i
don't agree with it
yeah i i agree that that's it doesn't um
i don't think it
i don't think it changes it in a way
that we
would be unhappy with i think it just
makes that clear um i'm happy to
take what we discussed today including
that including the um
uh the all boards councils and
commissions language uh that
representative goalie had mentioned um
actually i since
we've covered all of the changes you
wanted to make is that correct
yes yep okay then please send that
revised language to the full committee
so that we can go over it as we are
going section by section through uh
sb 133
sure and um
uh
chairwoman mcguire
when i i haven't yet done that do i send
it to you for distribution to the
subcommittee or should i or to the
committee or do i send it the listserv
or the send it to the the
list of the whole committee okay
for the benefit of the committee we will
be discussing
uh next tuesday we have an executive
session on senate bill 114
and we'll we'll
we will follow that by what
an exact session on
other bills as we can
senate bill 133 pam and i disagree on
whether it's an exec session or a
subcommittee or a work session but we'll
be going over each of the sections to
say do we pass it do we kill it or do we
amend it and then we will have
pam put together a final amendment
so that we can
vote on that at a subsequent executive
session
just to let you know what the plan is
madam chair which day did you say the
exec for 114
tuesday
thank you next tuesday the
fourth i think it is
we will have to have an exact session
after that because there is
also a work session on
uh
155 is on the sixth i believe as a
couple right there so we'll have to have
something the following week
right thank you and actually um
tom and lindsay b
i just saw lindsay's suggestion about
some changes for uh that she wants
included in here
i think they might be better in senate
bill
uh
52.
sure um
i i don't know if lindsay's on but not a
panelist i'm
i'm sure that's fine
to get in wherever it needs to get in
this is about the requirement that the
board signed the licenses
correct yep so if
that amendment i'm assigning to the
subcommittee um
it is equally applicable
to
52 and i think it's actually more
appropriate because it's a technical
change rather than a substantive change
okay
to skip an actual sub-committee meeting
or just the formality of what at our
next meeting can present this uh
the amendment with these basically
technical changes so it does i hope it
at this point i'm going to say uh
thank you and to you
to all for participating and before we
adjourn i'm going to invite mike and tom
to get back to work
okay
we're adjourned thank you
somebody
i'm going to try to be early enough next
time
oh
[Music]
whoops
um
uh pam are you on by any chance
yes i'm right here uh i'm going to need
report form it should be there on the
table that it had your name in a orange
sticky note um
near the chairman's chair one for a
packet for representative yakubovich and
i guess you can't see my red face thank
you
oh
hi
[Music]
uh
um
hello
today we read an announcement
the chair of the subcommittee on all of
the parts of sb133 with the exception of
part five and seven and probably the new
part 14.
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of the 19th pandemic
and in accordance with the house rule 67
and the government's emergency order
number 12
second order 2024
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
please note that there's no physical
location for members of the public to
emergency order i confirmed that all
members of the canadian select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate
[Music]
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic media platform
the public has access
to listen and if necessary participate
in the meeting by the same platform or
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the internet
calendar general website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa may 108.
anyone who's got a problem accessing me
should call 271
or email
hcs
please know that all votes are taken
during this meeting we should all be
done
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting which is required under the
right
and my wife is in the other room thank
you
representatives
mr chairman your sound is quite poor at
my end of things i'm wondering whether
representative fellows even heard your
call uh representative fellows are you
present
no you're good
i am here i i need to ask you to speak
up though
or or to put the microphone closer
it's always a challenge to hear the
people that are in the big room
representative roy
i am here um
alone
on the beach i would also ask you to
speak up because i can't hear you over
the sound of the waves
b
are you calling me mr chair i i don't
believe i'm on the subcommittee but i am
here
all right we'll record you
mr chairman if you want to record
representative o'brien equally as well
not on the committee but present and
alone i'll be just dropping him for a
bit
same for me mr chair this is
representative schultz
right
yes
yes to answer the 91 a restrictions i am
president of my home office in dover and
um this is representative fellows i
think i didn't tell you that part i'm
just tell them all right
we have representatives in the room with
so
um
let's open the work session for section
one of sb133
relative to the definition of licensing
agency for purposes of licensing places
yes mr chair i have my hand up
recognized
thank you i just wanted to say uh this
is rob ford uh
for changes made
recommended by the fire marshal and uh i
agree with these changes i think it's uh
a section that i i think is good and i'm
good with
thank you
oh i agree
else
um i this is representative fellows i'm
fine with this
section okay
all right i think we are ready for the
so that would be representative fellows
representative goalie
yes
let's move on to section
two
we have the testing from here
yes you two repealing the emergency
medical services personnel licensure
interstate compact
yes thank you
we have this discussion on it you're the
introduction
of the bill
would anybody
i would mr chair
just please representative roy
thank you mr chair
um
i i think that this uh bill if it ever
becomes necessary is premature
this compact was joined several years
ago however it just came into effect
last year in the middle of the pandemic
all i've read carefully all the
arguments against it and they're all
hypothetical every single one of them
this might happen that's bad this could
maybe potentially happen that's bad
but um
the arguments for it are real the
department of defense told us that this
would negatively affect
military families stationed at our air
base and actually put
in peril
the air base itself being located in new
hampshire which brings over a billion
dollars of money to the local economy
so
weighing those two things i just cannot
see why we would want to repeal this
right now
after it just came into effect and we
really don't know the results of it if
in the future at some point
the
hypothetical fears of the people against
it come to pass we can always revisit
this
and fine tune it but right now uh i just
don't think it's necessary to appeal
this your statute thank you
thank you mr chairman um
i do support this section um
i was on edna when this was uh
voted on and put into place and i was
against it then and i'm still against it
now um
i believe we are
jumping into something that we truly
don't know
what the effects are or what is going to
happen going on down the road um
using the excuse that we want to be on
board so we can have a seat at the table
i think is a poor excuse
um let this thing form uh we ought to
sit back see how it works see what
and this is with not just this compact
but the number of compacts we've gone
into um
i looked at and i pulled up the language
in the rsa
regarding this compact
and
it's the same boilerplate as all the
other compacts and to borrow accept a
contract for services of personnel
including but not limited to employees
of a member state to hire employees
elect or appoint officers fix
compensation define duties grant
individuals appropriate authority to
and it goes on and on
you know purchasing except appropriate
gifts donation otherwise
sell convey
i don't know how
big these compacts are planning to grow
and what the cost is going to be
but i think
we have the ability here
in new hampshire
if we need
help
use our mutual aid agreements with
surrounding states
um we also have
the power of the governor
to have reciprocity with those who are
already licensed if we need them in the
time of emergency declaring a state of
emergency without having this compact in
place
we've seen that under coven 19 the
biggest pandemic
we've had
not needing this
people going up
to other states for wildland fires and
this is a good thing so that they could
treat their personnel if needed
uh i i feel that if we're going to other
states for wildland fires
those states are under a state of
emergency and their governors could do
the same thing that our governor did
under this pandemic and have reciprocity
for these folks without this need being
needed
and for the fact that we talk about
um what ifs
i think the what if is also with the
closing of ps because we don't enact
this i think that's a hypothetical as
well i don't think it's justification i
don't think it would happen
um so i'm not sure why
that was brought up
um
with that being said uh the only other
issue i have is
these individuals
uh
understanding the standing protocols
as an emt i had to
do here in new hampshire with mitch's
fire department
protocol
updates and exams
to stay up to date with the state
protocols as we bring people in and out
of the state
for a weekly tour or
two-week tour or three-week tour who are
the protocols and
who are they going to be using
to cover that and i have
concerns about that as well
mr chairman there are a couple of hands
up in the attendee list i don't know if
you want to
recognize one one is identified as ems
compact and the other is chief justin
romanello
and if you'd like me to bring them over
okay i just have a question for
representative golly so you are
to clarify are you in favor of striking
this section or keeping in the bill
which will
effectively
is that right
could you repeat
that will effectively
nullify the compact agreement we have
right now
representative schmidt
uh thank you mr chairman uh i think i
better turn on my light shoulder
people can see me but uh
i i
i uh obviously appreciate representative
goldie's consistency i
position as in shade from when uh the
committee adopted this uh
compact a couple of years ago i served
on the subcommittee as did former
representative mark prue i spoke with
him uh and uh he was surprised to hear
that there was going to be an effort to
repeal the bill
uh to repeal the the compact i believe
that the our state's experience with
compacts has been
a very strong uh as a matter of fact
there are additional entities looking to
uh to join compacts uh with other states
uh that are currently under
consideration in other bills that we're
hearing um and uh the
the examination that i've
undertaken with regard to how those
compact
participants
looked at their compacts is that they
feel strongly that the compacts are
advantageous for the state advantages
for their profession and i agree with uh
representative roy's remark that the
compact on the replica has just gone
into effect we hardly have any
experience with it at all so to prejudge
it at this point i think is premature
especially given the fact that compacts
as a general rule in the state are very
favorably viewed
and and that they are desirable
so uh i hope that we'll hear from
uh people who are stakeholders uh as
uh
ms smarling has just indicated we have a
substantial attendance so let's hear
okay we'll do so at the end
uh thank you uh mr chairman as a guest
here committee thank you for allowing me
to speak but
when this comes before the full
committee i will speak the very same
sentiments to uh expedite things along i
agree with the position of
representative goalie 100
and
i i don't i think repealing this at this
time is not the way to go thank you
attendees
representative fellows um
thank you mr chair
um i i don't feel that i
have
i don't know very much about this
particular area of the compacts
but
my focus the thing that i that i did
care about
because i could understand it to some
extent is the
ability of
people from new hampshire to support
other states when they're dealing with
wildfires that sort of thing and that we
could get the same help
but as representative goalie said
you know we can we can do that through
other channels and i know we've been
doing for decades we've been providing
support for other states when they have
wildfires so if we could do it before
and seems like we can still do it that
we have somebody from the attendees you
yes um i don't know his name um he's
just identified as ems compact and then
chief justin romanello are both
with
the panel now
and so they both can unmute themselves
and speak and maybe give us a name
thanks
good good morning i i appreciate you uh
let me join you here for a moment my
name is dan manz i'm the educator for
the emergency medical services compact i
um i work for the interstate commission
for ems personnel practice we in ems
like to confuse everybody with acronyms
you know so
i work for the commission um replica
is the acronym we use for the
legislation so uh uh the terminology
kind of gets used interchangeably
my purpose in joining you today i just
wanted to
try and clarify some things that i think
may have come up in prior testimony that
um that that may be useful for you as
you go forward in thinking about a
decision on this particular bill
one of the questions was does the ems
compact allow out-of-state ambulance
services to operate in new hampshire
without
obtaining a new hampshire state
ambulance service license the quick
answer that is no
the compact legislation only applies to
qualified ems personnel the compact has
no authority there's no mention in the
compact law that relates to agencies or
vehicles and so the legislation you
currently have in place
doesn't change anything about new
hampshire's regulatory authority over
agencies ambulances
in any way it only extends the privilege
to practice to individually license ems
personnel from other compact member
states
it was referenced i heard earlier
compact did become operational this past
year
we've had hundreds of interstate
crossings related to covid's support as
well as
the historic 2020 wildland fires
out west i heard that also
mentioned i think it's important to note
that while
individual providers are authorized with
this privilege to practice the compact
also provides the receiving state with
legal authority over
the work of any out-of-state ems
personnel
another question i understood did come
up earlier was does the compact have any
effect on a community's mutual aid
arrangements again the quick answer to
that is no
because the compact legislation only
applies to personnel the compact really
has no authority or
involvement in how a community
chooses to arrange its
mutual aid
i think uh you may also have heard
testimony this um
compact does not change or interfere in
any way with emac the emergency
management assistance compact um if
there's a declared state of emergency in
new hampshire or any other compact
member state the provisions of emac
supersede
replica in that case
another item i heard i've heard
mentioned this morning was about the
out-of-state ems person's scope of
practice
section 4c of the legislation the model
legislation that new hampshire
previously adopted
addresses that question and it reads an
individual providing patient care in a
remote state under the privilege to
practice shall function within the scope
of practice authorized by the home state
where they came from
unless and until
modified by an appropriate authority in
the remote state
the the effect of that is that while the
default of the compact is the person
uses their home state scope of practice
if new hampshire felt that it needed to
modify that or control that in any way
the compact gives new hampshire full
authority to
to do that so you you don't give up in
any way um that that authority over
personnel entering new hampshire
i think it's it's also important to sort
of understand because again it was
mentioned that this is a fairly new
activation of this compact
what it is new hampshire would give up
by leaving the compact and i think one
of the
one of the things that sort of baked
into the loaf here with this is a level
quality platform for persons entering
new hampshire under the privilege to
practice provisions so the current
legislation as you have it
requires
uh
all of the
all of the member states in the compact
to use a common set of standards for
their personnel they all have to be
educated to national standards they have
to obtain certification from the
national registry of emts and they must
have passed an fbi fingerprint
background check and while most of the
compact states require that today the
fingerprint background check
specifically becomes effective on
october of uh 2022.
i can affirmatively state to you because
i'm coming to you this morning from the
great state of vermont right next door
where i used to be the state ems
director here that not all of the states
bordering new hampshire currently meet
all of those quality requirements
another thing new hampshire would give
up is access to
the national ems coordinated database
and and i'll just give you one
sort of example from my experience here
as the ems director in vermont we had an
applicant from out of state
come in apply for an emt license in
vermont check the box on the application
indicating you had no prior disciplinary
history or
license action in any other
state later as we were processing this
guy's application we got a call heard
through the grapevine that this person
had been diverting drugs in the state
that um he was moving from
it turned out he was a physician
assistant and an emt in another state um
i ended up calling the state and they
were able to share the information that
this guy had been under investigation
for diverting drugs in his work as a pa
the the practice board in the other
state was in the process of its final
hearing to revoke this guy's license
when he walked in and voluntarily
surrendered his pa license and and his
emt license he then moved to vermont
retook an emt class sought licensure in
this state never disclosed the the
background he was being investigated for
in another state
the
database
that the compact states share would
enable new hampshire to see that kind of
information that investigatory
information and license action
license action information for
over 300 000 ems personnel that are in
the compact today
who
could move to new hampshire and seek
license in new hampshire at some point
in the future
um it would also you lose the ability to
revoke an out-of-state person's
privilege to practice if someone came in
from out of state um today
um you have the ability if they come
from a compact state to curtail remove
their scope of practice
just as you could remove the license
from any person you issued a license to
um
currently
in new hampshire if you remove a
person's privilege to practice they lose
it in every other compact state and
their home state agrees to investigate
whatever happened in new hampshire just
as if it had happened in the uh in the
home state incredibly powerful tool that
you end up with in new hampshire to
control bad practice from other people
final point
i think has been alluded to that new
hampshire would become
less military friendly by exiting this
compact
the compact provides military personnel
and their families expedited processing
of license applications as well as the
privilege to practice when they move
around around between compact member
state
sorting out all of the license
requirements paying the fees and waiting
to find work in the civilian sector are
all complexities of military life and
that's really the reason that the
military so strongly supports
these health occupational licensing
compacts
so
in summary
compact does not allow agencies from
member states to cross borders and
perform ems duties doesn't affect the
community's mutual aid agreements
new hampshire retains full control over
the scope of practice of ems personnel
entering the state
having new hampshire
withdraw from the compact erodes some
important public protection elements and
it could create a situation where new
hampshire is viewed as less military
friendly so i thank you i just wanted to
clarify those points and i'll i'll stay
on if there's any questions i could help
with
thank you mr chair i
would just like to respond to some of
that because i i think it's
a shame at this time and uh in this
place if we can't have a national we
have to be part of a compact to find out
someone inside a licensed revoked um i i
think it's wrong
and there's a problem with the system if
that's what's happening
second i'd like to uh follow up on uh we
hear that well they can continue with
state protocols but yet we heard they
come here under their home state
protocols until we determine whether
they abide by new hampshire protocols
um
i don't know if there's a registry or a
database when someone crosses compact to
compact state lines that they must
immediately notify
the bureau of ems here in new hampshire
that they've come from another compact
state and are practicing here for that
for a point of time
how do we address the issues of
protocols and determine when the
home state license protocol is
transferred over to new hampshire
protocol because i heard conflicting um
information there as to they go along
with home state until it's determined by
new hampshire that they use our
protocols and which protocols i mean
um
they have to be practicing uh i know in
manchester we had to have a medical
director um our hospital is the elliott
hospital uh with manchester fire um so
it's gonna it's gonna
be different from uh
different communities across the state
of new hampshire as to who the medical
director is that they're practicing on
there as well as the protocols that they
will um
so with that um and i also think that
in treating the military individuals
we have the ability to right here in new
hampshire law we can change that and
address the issues to expedite military
families
with licensing
thank you
thank you um
oh thank you i i was first of all i was
hoping that the witness could respond to
a representative goalie's concerns and
then i had a question myself
okay could we do that
please
sure what what specifically would you
well he he just said some concerns about
uh scope of practice and uh when they
would fall into new hampshire protocols
versus their home state protocols um if
you could respond to that also
also it just it seems like um it seems
like we're talking about um this worry
about people coming into the state and
just setting up shop and not reporting
and starting to practice isn't it true
that they can't until they get a license
in the state either via the compact or
actual new hampshire license i mean no
one's going to come in and set up their
own ems shop are they
and this is chief romano can i can i
answer that just from our perspective
from the bureau of ems it it might help
a little bit
if the representative roy is okay with
that i believe he will
i'd like to hear actually from both i'd
like to hear from the compact itself and
the chief would be great too all right
chief please
sorry about the interruption
um i i do want to explain uh just one
piece with with new hampshire so um
and it ties into the the comments that
that uh the compact had made so so in
new hampshire 153 a is our governor
governor rsa and so with ems the only
entities in the state that have the
legal ability to provide ems services
are licensed ems units as an individual
provider i'm a paramedic i cannot
provide ems care unless i have an
affiliation with a licensed ems unit why
that's important here is
in as the combat stated with section
four
is that automatically based on our rules
an out-of-state provider coming in from
uh from their home state into us being a
remote state would have to automatically
follow new hampshire rules and so with
that as a provider they would have to
follow what's required by the licensed
unit to perform care so medical
direction medical resource hospital
which is a
mechanism in which the unit gets their
medical direction and their ability to
practice all is based on the unit so
those providers automatically would have
to fall in line with new hampshire ems
protocols at the time they begin uh
practicing under that licensed ems unit
and so um i think that would uh
addresses that concern right off the bat
so as an example i i won't pick on
anybody in particular but i'll use
representative goalie's example with
manchester fire if they needed personnel
and they called from personnel out of a
remote state and they came to manchester
fire manchester fire would have to put
them on the their roster
allow them access to the the ability to
to write ems run reports as a member of
the ems agency
and and then also they would be
responsible providing care based on new
hampshire protocols because that unit
has fallen under elliot hospital's
medical direction
and as their medical resource hospital
so that would that would take care of
that that issue right off the bat as
soon as the unit requested the
assistance from an out-of-state uh ems
agency for that matter
also it was mentioned about
the ability to practice and so in in 153
820 which is the commissioner of the
department of safety's ability to to
make rules there's a separate section
there that further provides protection
to the state of new hampshire from
individuals coming into our state under
under the compact and that that rule at
the paraphrase essentially says
emergency medical service units licensed
under rsa 153 a10 shall not use
emergency medical service providers who
are privileged to practice from a remote
state under the compact in regular and
usual staff and patterns
or personnel so this is just a further
protection so
why do we even need the compact at this
point right we can't use it for
day-to-day operations well i think covet
is a is a great example
uh as of when we we could use could have
used a compact and the reason why we
didn't is is i'm biased because i'm from
new hampshire but we did a phenomenal
job of protecting our providers we had
minimum ppe requirements that enabled
them to not be infected they were super
vigilant when they were providing
patient care in in limiting their
ability to do certain interventions
that were that were uh would have put
them in a higher danger of infecting the
disease so we did a great job with not
having any outbreaks at
an agency now if we did
mutual aid would certainly be uh be
utilized but if we found that there was
multiple outbreaks and that caused
system system issues
we certainly may have required the use
of the compact and maybe it would have
been more with the private entities
providing 911 services because they had
ability to pull from out of state
but either way i think that our
response to kovid prevented the
necessary the necessity of using the
compact but it certainly could have been
an example to it um and certainly here
to answer any questions or or follow up
with any comments thank you for your
time thank you
representative roy do you have further
questions
uh only uh well i do but i wanted to see
if the compact wanted to respond as well
yeah thanks i you know i agree with the
everything chief uh romanello shared
there um i think as a as a practical
matter um you know an emt entering or
paramedic entering new hampshire under
the compact privilege to practice um
as he explained your state laws already
require affiliation with an ems agency
and that agency is going to be allowing
that person use of the equipment
use of the communications use of the
necessary elements for that person to
practice and it makes logical sense in
new hampshire that the person will
follow new hampshire's scope of practice
um i think as a practical matter
you know
thinking that
ultimately other new england states will
enter the compact which i believe is
true and ultimately some of the cross
border activity may occur with
personnel from surrounding new england
state the new england states have been
working for a number of years on moving
very closely together in their clinical
protocols and scopes of practice so as a
practical matter the differences are
pretty subtle today i think between what
happens in new hampshire and what
happens in the other new england state
but um to the extent that's a critical
point for new hampshire
you you've got the control and the way
people practice as an affiliate of an
agency
logically leads to them following the
new hampshire protocols and scope of
practice
thank you representative golly could i
ask a question now oh oh sorry i'm sure
representative roy
thank you mr chairman um
this question can go to either the chief
or the contact um
we've heard a lot of discussion about
you know fire fighting fires out west if
there's a
when we're not talking about
firefighters are we i mean we're talking
about ems and i was wondering
if we could get a real world example and
not use covet because this was fast
before covert so there must have been a
need seen for this before coviz can can
we get a real world example of like
who would use this how and why
um
just something so we can you know sink
our teeth and understand what this
really is and who would really be using
this sure i i mean i can probably
provide you with that um
the
state of colorado was a big user of the
compact they're a member of the compact
they had significant wildfire activity
in the past year and um had a number of
personnel
come in as part of their wildland
firefighting crews who were in fact
providing ems support to those personnel
deployed
on the on the fire lines in the past
this created complexity for colorado
colorado had to receive applications
from these people had to issue temporary
licenses or create some other process
to enable these people to practice
within colorado legally
the colorado ems director and i've
spoken about this a number of times he
said man life just got easy you see with
the compact because people would come in
from um out of state we knew uh you know
we knew what their training was
we knew what they were able to do
um it would authorize we didn't have to
take any action on them um at all to
enable and authorize their practice we
knew they were working under appropriate
medical direction and he said and it it
solved the problem for those people
because colorado was taking time to
process those applications during times
when things needed to move very very
quickly so they they viewed it as a huge
huge help and um that it worked out very
well in i i don't know how many cases
but
um i think we're talking into the tens
or hundreds of cases that they used it
for wildland fire
support thank you
thank you mr chairman i just continue to
say that i think under a state of
emergency
governor done the same thing here and i
guess i would ask
the chief
isn't the uh
emergency orders or executive orders by
the governor to allow temporary
licensure another way to get around this
and if in the time of
needed care
it certainly certainly could be um we
didn't so it was something that we had
on our radar if it was necessary we saw
massachusetts do some some pretty
drastic uh temporary waivers with their
license we didn't we didn't need to in
this response but it is a tool i think
that um
in my experience with cobit there um
there were certainly some delays um and
i think that having the compact would
would alleviate those delays
in in a ideal world if we had people
around us that were able to use you know
that we could benefit from um you know
so i think it's it could be
if if we needed to make something happen
immediately i think the compact would
would be beneficial in that case but
certainly governor can can make those uh
emergency rules and orders and and we
can get the same effects uh if if we
didn't have the compact but the i think
the benefit is we do have the compact
server
thank you follow up
hello
i still need some clarification because
i've heard two different scenarios and
i'm not sure which is correct um
dealing with protocols
the initial
i heard was they would be dealing under
their home state protocol until
it is caught later on whether the state
wants them under their state protocol
then i heard as soon as they come here
they are under state protocol what's the
correct answer
so i i think it's
because the way the the
replica and the compact is written to to
accommodate the 22 21 states that are in
it
so there has to be some flexibility in
in
with with the interpretation of that as
as the state uh ems official my
interpretation of that is based on how
we license units and providers in the
state and that it's it's spelled out in
153 that the only entities in our state
that can provide care are licensed ems
units i think as soon as somebody comes
in from from their home state into us as
a remote state that my interpretation
and how that rule would be applied is
that they now fall under new hampshire
protocols based on the fact that the
unit is is what is delivering the care
and how our licensed units deliver care
is through the use of licensed ems
providers or in this case providers that
are given that privilege of practice
one last follow-up follow up
and
prior to patient care and working under
new hampshire protocols is there any
exam they're required to take to show
uh competency and protocols
so they would
again my interpretation is that as soon
as somebody came in they would
and they have to operate under our
protocols then they would have to
satisfy the the scope of practice
requirements that we have in the
protocol exam real well i mean again
that would be that would be our
requirements once they enter is that if
they're working on our protocols they
they would have to follow that the the
um the paramedic scope practice or emt
scope of practice and protocol rollout
so um and that would be
essentially uh completed or required and
completed through the agency in the
medical resource hospital
thank you
and
in what time frame follow up
um so i'll be honest with you sir we
don't have a time frame i would it would
have to happen before
they assume
the ability to practice uh to start
practicing patient care so um i mean
you know this protocol rollout
it would it took me two hours to
complete it at the paramedic level um so
it's not a huge time requirement so you
know to me if if there was
uh you know i see a christie christie
was on here so if amr needed personnel
and and he called for assistance from
other amr units that are members of
combat states then my expectation would
be is as soon as they came in they would
need to practice under new hampshire
protocols and that part of the request
would be that they would have to meet
these requirements uh read the
requirements of the protocol rollout and
they can do that you know online for
that matter so i don't see
there being any interruption or any care
delivered not to the new hampshire
standard based on the fact that they
would be operating through that that
home new hampshire licensed agency and
before they can have access to the
abilities to provide care and the
resources they would need to meet that
standard
and that would be my expectation and if
they failed to do that then it would be
you know we would have the ability to to
investigate through compliance our
compliance department to ensure that
that is happening
thank you um
this is not quite the public hearing we
already had that
um so can we please stay brief
if possible in the future
representative
roy thank you mr chairman and uh in
keeping with that very briefly
um
this question goes to again either the
chief or the combat
we've heard that the
same
result can be obtained through a
governor's emergency order for expedited
licensure but with an emergency order
for expedited licensure give us access
to the interstate database
and
is there anything else that we would not
be able to do just because we announced
this extra relationship to the
governor's executive order thank you
thank you
yeah let me tackle that one and you're
you're correct that um that's one of the
things you would give up you would not
have access to the
to the coordinated database and um and
accordingly your your governor could
under emergency circumstances say we'll
um you know we'll allow an emt from any
other state
to enter um new hampshire and work under
these exigent circumstances um you know
the downside of that is you you really
don't know affirmatively how was that
person educated you don't know how that
person was tested you don't have
assurance that they have medical
direction from their home state and you
wouldn't be able to see them in the
database you know it was it was
mentioned earlier gosh we got to be able
to find out if these people are licensed
you know or have licenses revoked in
another state a
great idea that's really what this
compact provides and it's what does not
exist without this compact
thank you
um we have a few more witnesses
if we can go through them maybe also on
the brief side please
who's next stan
um uh chris stay was
thank you uh i'll be brief and
defer to everybody's time i just want to
reiterate that i believe um that the
benefits of this compact far outweigh
any potential risks that are out there
new hampshire participates in upwards of
40 interstate licensure compacts i don't
know of any that we've exited i also
don't know of any that have been put
under the microscope as much as this one
has in in the recent past
i think that particularly in the middle
of a worldwide pandemic taking any tool
out of our toolbox as the people that
are responsible for the health and
safety of the citizens of this state is
irresponsible and we would support
examining this further looking at other
protections that we could add to it but
exiting is just not um it just doesn't
who's next
christopher arnold from the department
of defense is next and we do have two
more um attendees in the attendee list
that i'll promote
okay
thank you so much and i'm so happy to be
here uh
good to see everyone again uh i'll
you know respond to the earlier question
um certainly the secretaries of the
military departments have made the
importance of military spouse licensure
explicitly clear as they consider the
availability of license reciprocity when
evaluating future basing or mission
alternatives
and that consideration was codified by
congress as a requirement in the 2020
national defense authorization act
section 2883 which i encourage you all
to read and you can see copy of in my
testimony from the hearing the
secretaries must consider whether the
state in which an installation subject
to a basing decision is or will be
located has entered into reciprocity
agreements to recognize and accept
professional and occupational licensure
and certification credentials granted by
or in other states or allows for the
transfer of such licenses and
certifications granted by or in other
states
so lessons that we've learned through
actions taken by states along with the
lessons from other initiatives such as
the national conference of state
legislatures the national governors
association the council of state
government's licensing consortium
provided dod an opportunity to consider
a working definition of reciprocity
our definition of reciprocity represents
less of an absolute interpretation of
the dictionary definition and more of a
description of a continuum of
opportunities for military spouses to
transfer an occupational license between
states which is why we advocate
for a variety of solutions
simultaneously
in the immediate term
uh the short term and over the long term
compacts allow a practitioner to work in
multiple states without re-licensing
since these compacts are defined by
occupation and improved by the states
they take time to enact however
significant progress has been made on
obtaining the approval of existing
compacts for example in rhode island
governor mckee has put six of the seven
health occupation compacts in his 2021
budget proposal in connecticut governor
lamont's budget bills have a study of
five major health compacts including
replica to be completed by this fall and
in massachusetts governor baker's
executive order from january ordered a
similar study with reporting to the
governor uh due later or no later than
one july including the nine uh
occupations that are evaluated by the
department of the air force and their
basing criteria
which includes ems so i have a call with
a new england state later today and the
spouse of the army chief of staff the
spouse of the space force cso the spouse
of the chief of the air guard and
several others where we are discussing
the benefits of compacts with the senior
leadership in that state these states
have been listening closely to the
department of defense and our services
over the year that licensure compacts
are the preferred end state by dod and
the military services to obtain full
reciprocity the department has found
profession-specific interstate compacts
for licensing to be the most beneficial
and achievable alternative interstate
compact requires states to approve them
in law to join and as a result compacts
take time to become more effective
instead of counting compacts as relevant
to the currently
available licensing opportunities
we consider a state's commitment to or
we consider them as provi
proving a state's commitment to
providing full reciprocity in the future
uh
thereby
repealing a compact would would be
moving in the opposite direction from
how uh we we evaluate that commitment
from the states so i'm happy to answer
any questions that the panel may have
and thank you so much for your time
thank you
who's next pam
uh um
i think it must be um eric shelberg
you can unmute yourself oh
okay
morning thank you very much for
allowing me the opportunity to speak and
i will be very brief
i would just like to
i'm representing the new hampshire
paramedic association
and we are very much in support of
keeping replica so we would like to see
part two stricken from this amended bill
and specifically we are looking at not
to rehash what has been said of what i
support i do support and we do support
for what has been mentioned today
but this also allows for new hampshire
with replica to this can be a force
multiplier for us in times of emergency
or in times when additional personnel
are needed
for specific activities
not for day-to-day operations
and so it's another tool in toolbox
and also if there is movement by the
legislative body to reduce or to
restrict the governor's emergency power
orders
this could be a tool that
stays in place that will not be affected
by that if something like that were to
pass
thank you very much for your time
thank you
i have a question mr chairman of this uh
this last testifier yes please
thank you very much
uh
so
up to now we've mostly been speaking
about emergency situations but i was
thinking all along and you kind of
triggered it off again with your remarks
that in an emergency situation clearly
the governor can
declare that emergency or address that
emergency
but we i can imagine there might be
other circumstances and you kind of
alluded to that uh where it's not an
emergency situation where the governor
could not
uh you know
act in that capacity
uh and
uh so the compact it
seems to me would uh give us additional
uh uh
capabilities can you speak to that a
um
as i understand
from the compact that if there were a
large scale
activity that were to happen
this could allow for personnel to be
moved in
however i will defer that to mr manns
and or chief romanello
okay
all right
i i'd be happy to try and tackle that
one
i'm sorry i'm sorry
can i go to representative schultz i'm
sorry end up oh thank you mr chair i
actually had a question
for mr arnold
um
i admire the work you're doing to make
sure that military spouses are
accommodated
and certainly i think all of us
appreciate the service of our military
very much so
i'm wondering though
have you worked with any states that
have looked at devising like you know
writing language at the state level
to
um
assist military spouses
through our
licensing um
without
going through a compact is that is that
something you're aware of or worked on
yourself or have any uh
language that you would recommend
uh that's a fantastic question and i
believe i did uh speak to that briefly
in my in my testimony uh at the hearing
last week but yes uh our office which is
in effect the state government arm of
the department of defense uh has been
dealing with military spouse licensure
uh since 2004
and we've passed about 700 pieces of
legislation uh over the last 17 years so
uh we advocate for a variety of
approaches simultaneously
our goal is for a license to be issued
within 30 days that is the
the baseline outcome uh that we are
looking for
however
uh like i said we're looking for a
variety of approaches simultaneously
because a state
specific uh approach does not always
encompass the same definition of of
reciprocity from
one state to another so if you can
guarantee that someone's going to get
their license when they're coming to new
hampshire in 30 days that's wonderful
but what about the new hampshire
domiciled spouse who's serving at
vandenberg air force base uh in
california you cannot guarantee that
that person is going to get a license in
30 days
which is why the compacts present uh the
optimal
end state goal
for a 50 state license reciprocity does
that answer your question representative
schultz
yes it does and i appreciate that
you probably did address it in your
initial testimony but i'm listening to
things differently now so
um i just want to plant that seed i get
why from your point of view
compacts certainly simplify the process
across state borders but if we go in the
direction of not going with a compact
i'd love to
circle back with you to see if we can
still accommodate spouses in some way
the
compact approach uh is is not
all-encompassing in that there's not a
compact for every occupation nor is
every state a member of each compact in
the 2019 national defense authorization
act there was a requirement for the
secretary of defense to enter into a
cooperative agreement with what is known
as the center for interstate compacts
which is part of the council of state
governments to develop new
occupational interstate licensing
compacts and just last month we did the
press release announcing the first five
occupations that were selected
for funding which include
teachers
social workers dental and dental
hygienists massage therapists and
cosmetologists but as you know new
hampshire probably has over 50
occupational boards and even with five
more compacts coming online that would
be a total of 12. so
for those other occupations uh we look
at what we call an expedited approach on
our continuum but again the word
expedited is something that varies from
state to state so
are you talking about uh expedited in
that we'll just move your occupation to
the front of the pile but then it sits
there for six months while we're
verifying that the algebra you took in
is the the same in new hampshire as it
is uh in maine uh or does it mean that
you know your your application is going
to be processed with a minimum of
paperwork and a minimum of fees so one
approach that we've seen states take
right across the border
in maine
working with their division of
professional licensure and regulation
commissioner
and head
we have a departmental bill
that was reported favorably from their
professional licensure committee and
will likely be enacted this year
that would allow a military spouse uh
upon submission of an affidavit to
receive a license within 30 days if that
affidavit indicates that they uh meet
the
standards to practice the occupation in
maine and essentially they'll issue them
a temporary license uh uh while they
pursue whatever state specific
requirements there are and that's a
great approach for getting
inside of our best practice
for that license within 30 days when
you're in the state of maine but the
compacts
are are the most optimal state in that
they represent a national standard for
competency and they work both inside and
outside of the state uh which is why we
advocate for both approaches
simultaneously
thank you mr arnold i think we're moving
a little out of scope for this
subcommittee
so thank you mr chair i appreciate your
your
generosity
thank you representative schultz
um next there's um brian rill or i'm not
sure about the pronunciation but all
right he's here you can pronounce that
correctly believe it or not thank you so
much for being great um brian real i
represent uh the professional
firefighters of new hampshire uh we have
about 2000 active and retired uh
professional firefighters and paramedics
throughout the state um i did speak in
uh the hearing the other day so i'm not
going to restate
my testimony for you all i just wanted
to draw some attention to a couple of
things
that have kind of caught my ear this
morning and while i
utterly respect the testimony in favor
of replica i think it's important to
note that
what we're hearing right now
is a lot of confusion and a lot of
contradictory uh testimony
and
[Music]
a few examples of that
we've stated
that this is not intended to be for
day-to-day use that this is for
um
you know significant emergencies that
the governor does not activate the emac
but while you look at the language of
the law on the first paragraph it states
that it's for
uh day-to-day use uh and the day-to-day
movement of personnel uh that's one area
that i think that this is causing some
confusion
uh additionally
we
while i respect uh chief romanello's
testimony one of the things that
concerns me um is
uh that a lot of this is going to rely
on his interpretation of the law
um and
while i think that um in many cases
that's that's
fine and and well and just i think that
it concerns me uh that the law is not
explicitly stated so that we can
understand truly what the ramifications
uh of this uh really have for ems
providers throughout the state and
and thirdly i think that there's been
significant
um
contradictory testimony as to whether or
not this was used during this pandemic
or not
some have stated that it was used and
some have stated that it has not been
used
i think what's important to note
is that we in fact have not had to
utilize the replica model throughout
this pandemic
we've been under a state of emergency
and our ems system has been able to
weather the storm
and provide
ex exemplary service without having
glitches in that system and i think a
lot of the reason for this is because uh
we're in a very densely populated area
here in the new england states where we
have a robust uh mutual aid system and
mutual aid agreements that are developed
at the local level
and when you start
looking at some of these rural
communities or you start looking at the
midwestern states where um ems services
are
less densely populated
it's clear that there may be the need
for that in those states
however we are simply looking for a
solution to a problem that we do not
have we provide an excellent service as
it is without the replica model in use
and i think it's it's
you know we need to talk about
hypotheticals
you really are doing a disservice to the
state when you start uh changing a
system that is currently functioning as
it's supposed to um so with that i will
say that um i uh completely support the
repeal of replica and support leaving
this as part of
the current bill thank you so much thank
uh thank you mr chairman if uh there are
no other witnesses to testify i would
like to make a motion and speak to my
motion
yep
go ahead representative roy
uh there being no further testimony at
this time i would like to make a motion
that
um the subcommittee make a
recommendation to the full committee
that
the
uh they'll be amended so it's the strike
section two in its entirety
and uh i'm happy to speak to that now if
just to interject i'm sorry mr chairman
there was a doug wolfberg that that
raised his hand um
late and so he is a panelist i don't
know if he
wants to chime in
yeah i know
would you like to withdraw the motion
for a moment mr roy i represented roy
i leave that to your pleasure i'm not
sure if you think we've heard enough
[Music]
thank you very brief i am legal counsel
a replica and also uh for the council of
state governments and we strongly
support uh new hampshire staying in the
compact uh which is a csg priority
uh and the one thing i wanted to comment
on briefly is
with the scope of practice issue just to
put a bow around that testimony i i
really think it's important to sort of
know that uh there's more and more
health professions are moving toward
evidence-based practice we're seeing
differences in state standards of care
and state scopes of practice really
level off you know compared to where
they were 20 years ago where it was more
you know what a medical director sort of
favored uh you know kind of this is the
way i've always done it sort of practice
and evidence-based medicine is really
moving ems systems toward a much more
standardized practice most of the
differences you see are in what kind of
equipment you know will we use this
particular device and we use that
particular device
uh so the medic just you know kind of
uses what's available to them so i just
wanted to make that comment and and
that's all i wanted to add thank you
very much thank you
representative roy
yes i like to reintroduce my motion that
the subcommittee recommends to the full
committee that section two be amended
struck it out in its entirety and i'd
thank you
um so we've heard testimony from state
health officials
state ems providers the federal
government all in favor of remaining in
this contract the only testimony we've
heard against it is from the state
firefighters union
um we're not talking about a new bill
this is a bill that was already vetted
and passed
and at the time i don't recall that the
firefighters union uh opposed it so vice
versa i'm not sure what brought this up
speaking of you know a problem fixing a
problem that doesn't exist this statue
has not caused any problems we've just
now started to get it up and running
and i think that
the work of previous committees and
everyone that went into getting this
involved deserved to
let's try this thing and see how it
works we're always able to withdraw
later
i just think that it's
when we hear it all the testimony
it was all upsides that were real worlds
it would really benefit military spouses
both in the state and out of the state
that means new hampshire citizens who
were in the military and were stationed
in a compact state and vice versa
we've heard from ems providers how this
can provide
real world benefits
we've heard that even if the governor
made an order that would allow
expedited licensure we won't be able to
review the background of these people in
a quick fashion
we wouldn't know anything about them
this compact addresses that
so having heard all that
i would just wrap up by saying that
again
the vast majority of the testimony we've
heard
is for this
and um
and it provides real world benefits
versus the hypothetical negatives from
the folks that are against it so thank
you
thank you i concur
thank you mr chair and i will be voting
i look at this uh i was here when this
was passed um there were a number of
folks against it at that time um me
being one of them and i still am i don't
think
um like i stated before
having a seat at the table is
necessarily the right reason to jump in
to be the first in helping make the
rules and do
such with this compact
um
i look at some of the problems i know
this is boilerplate language for csg for
all of their compacts and i have issues
with
that
allowing these compacts to go and
purchase lease or
have a mortgage on places we don't know
where the money is coming from where
it's going hiring employees
the scope of how big this is going to
grow or where it's going
i also look at what the cost is going to
be here to the state of new hampshire as
we further on go down the road we heard
just the other day in the nursing
compact that they've hired their first
employee and are growing from that point
um after being in place for quite some
time and i think all these compacts are
going to be doing the same and that's
why this language has put their
boilerplate they're meant to grow
meant to uh have a fee associated with
them and uh have a cost to them um
another concern i have uh
and looking at this was
that the
um these members have qualified immunity
defense and indemnification
um
why they need that i'm not sure why
should they be free and clear from shall
be immune from suit and liability in
their official capacity for any claim or
damage
i'm not sure why they need that
um so i have an issue with that that's
in all of these contacts about these uh
folks that are on a commission
um
i also look at um
there is language in there that deals
with the military it's um that we could
easily put into new hampshire statute
that says we will assist in
um
license um in a timely manner
for uh those military families if you
look at the languages it's a
pretty easy to put into new hampshire
statutes to make sure we take care of
the military individuals
the compact
isn't needed to do that
each state can do that
quite simply just by using the language
that's in here
giving priorities to our military folks
so for that reason
i'm going to vote against this motion
thank you
thank you representative um peter
schmidt
thank you mr chairman i don't believe
i'm a member of the subcommittee so i
don't have a vote
not the clerk please call the role
representative
did you call me
yes representative roy
yes
no
representative fellows
yes
thank you
could you repeat that mr chairman we
just couldn't hear you oh yeah yeah
we're done with this section we're going
to the next one section three
we didn't hear the results of the voting
section three
relative to hearings of the new hunter
which it's a short section it takes out
would anybody like to speak about it
section 3 part 3
of the bill
um
representative fellows
yes just to just to um
kind of
reiterate what we heard
for testimony on this bill
that
all it does is
open up to some other members
the ability to be chair
and to be a chair doesn't really give
you any special
privilege it just means that you're the
one
recognizing the people to speak and
keeping the process moving along in the
appropriate protocols so i support this
bill
thank
thank you
if not um
anybody can make a motion you don't see
motion on this section
i make a motion to keep
keep this in the bill
second
yes
representative roy
five zero
recommend it
okay moving on to part four
membership of the professional
would anybody like to speak about part
four of the bill
uh representative fellows
um
yes mr chair thank you i used to work at
the department of education for 30 years
so
um i'm familiar with
this
although i wasn't part of it i'm
familiar with
these two
the um i'm familiar with that board
and
i think the change to um
designate the number of
higher education and um k-12 education
representatives
is appropriate and the split is good
because the majority of what they deal
with in their book in their work is on
the k-12 side
and
in terms of the second change which just
says instead of saying somebody may only
serve
two terms it says it changes it to be
two consecutive terms and i think that's
that's absolutely fine there may be
somebody who
really can contribute a lot and it's um
nice to let them come back after a break
so that there's a rotation of
people that are sitting on the board and
you just don't have the same board all
the time
myself i you know i didn't
i had trouble with this section
because
it seems like limitations are being
introduced
so you designate a specific number of
people
did you have a question about it
no just it just wasn't my concern
can you say that again because i wasn't
clear
you know what you said it seems like
it's limiting it can be
elected
oh oh okay um if i can just respond i
the way i look at it is it just keeps it
may i make a motion
yes please
um i make a motion to keep this in the
bill
second
now
yes
representative phillips
i
you need to re can you please speak up
when you're doing the voting because i
i guess the next the next possible thing
second
discussion uh would you like to speak uh
represent the fellows
um
you had your hand up
no um just to reiterate what i said
before i think this is a reasonable
change in it the split is
in proportion
to what they deal with
mr chair
yes please mr gold representative
thank you i just i don't i'm not sure i
heard the reason for the objection to
could someone just let me know what the
objection is
oh my objection yes thank you my
objection was
we're restricting the composition of the
board and then
yeah i don't have a good feeling about
second parties but primarily restriction
in the
board composition thank you
the representative roy
on itl
i'm voting yes on the itl however i am
open to have my mind change at the full
committee work session so whoever is
supporting this
please be prepared to change it
clerk votes yes
representative no
no
representative fellows
and chair
yes
so the ita passes
the itl passes 3-2
so
um can i ask representative roy what he
yes please
thank you representative fellows uh
basically the same concerns uh voiced by
uh
the chair
i'd like to just understand it further
we can discuss it at the work session
so
the next part
mr chairman we do have a member of the
public out in the attendees um we have
two
um that would have their hands up sure
or
i would probably
as far as time goes i would probably
break for lunch for an hour between noon
and one or something like that
once we're done with this section
mr chair yes please
um i have an appointment to donate blood
and
um to the red cross
and it's at 3 30
so
i need to leave maybe
like at 3 10
and
i did a lot of research on the very last
section of this bill the one that has to
do with
with uh food codes
yep
um so it would be possible to to take
that up
um
you know
and allow a little bit of time for a
discussion on that but
um before i have to leave okay
thank you damn you said 3 10 is it um i
okay yeah we can do that after lunch
that will be section 12.
i think
would any um subcommittee members like
to talk about
section
all right
[Music]
how many members from the public do we
have
we have three now we have judy simpson
nicole o'malley and susan adams
okay
[Music]
so alphabetically it'd be judy simpson
first
if you can limit it to say two minutes
because we've had hearings on this
for a while for a number of years now
thank you
thank you so much mr chairman and to the
committee um my name is judy simpson i'm
the director of government relations for
the american music therapy association
and based on feedback from last week's
public hearing we have sent amendment
language to
our sponsors i'm not sure if you've
received it we sent it to representative
mcgee and senator evard
um
basically replacing
the current section that describes the
practice of music therapy section 5
within this category
and using language that was recently
passed just within the last couple of
weeks in the state of maryland
the language in maryland was agreed to
by the american speech language hearing
association that state association
representing slps and the music
therapists as well as the legislators so
we're confident that it addresses the
concerns that were raised last week
and it clearly outlines that music
therapists do not replace slps and that
if they're working with anyone with a
communication disorder that they
collaborate and review treatment plans
with the slp so
we feel like it addresses the concerns
that were
mentioned in the public hearing and it's
our effort to move the section forward
so that music therapists can attain
licensure in the state i'm open to any
questions
thank you i have not received
any amendments yet
our plan is not to really amend anything
in the subcommittee but to do so in the
full committee
so there's time for that
so with that something i should send to
you directly or to
to all of us at edna
be happy to do that but like i said it's
the language directly just passed in
maryland and it was what was requested
last week by
the asha susan adams who's also on this
call
thank you yeah if yeah
the full committee needs to see it
because i'm sure it'll be discussed
yes sir
thank you
so
uh next please
uh nicole o'malley would be next
hi my name is nicole o'malley i'm the
government relations representative for
the new england region of the american
music therapy association i am the
director of the music therapy program at
the university of rhode island um as
well in the task force chair here and
i'm here um to provide an overview rhode
island went through similar um
legislation in 2014 with our license um
enacted in 2015
um and the increase in accessibility and
frankly the degree program at the state
university um would not have been
plausible without the licensure there's
increase in access
we are working with insurance companies
we
co-treat and always have very closely
with
speech and language pathologists
and there have been um
quite a bit more access points to
clients which is really where this is is
coming from you know it's the people
that we work
um for the people that we serve um that
have so many struggles because of the
systematic and even misrepresentation we
now have increased opportunities for
other artists and musicians and there's
just been a significant change um
over the past five years so i'm here in
support and i any questions please email
me or someone has their hand up i don't
know if that's to me so
i'm open
[Music]
uh representative schmidt please
thank you very much mr chair uh and
we cannot hear you
i i hit the unmute but it didn't work um
so now i've got it sorry uh so thank you
very much for your testimony uh and of
course the issue is going to be the
language that was just proposed i
understand we can't move forward because
we don't have the actual amendment but
uh
is this an issue that you're familiar
with
who's the question too
it's it's to the
young lady that just spoke
all right
all right please
i am um
i again i was the task force chair we
had similar challenges and worked with
our local asha chapter um judy would be
probably more she's our national
government relations rep so she is more
well-versed as this has come up in
other states as well and the language
he's proposing again passed in maryland
after this has occurred in multiple
states my state was before maryland
because it was five years ago so um
maryland is very very current
okay well you you understand that the
issue
yeah thank you mr chairman so uh the the
the issue is whether this language is
acceptable because we've all the
committee has already several times
supported uh music therapy uh in theory
it didn't pass the senate last time
because of the pandemic situation so the
the question is whether the marijuana
language is acceptable
we want to see we see these two uh
professions as complementary not
oppositional
uh and so we would like to be sure that
we have a true compromise between the
music therapists and the speech
pathologists
um so that language is going to be the
acceptability of the language is going
to be key to us
so if you can if you can
get your colleagues to uh be prepared to
uh
contact us before the sub before the
full committee meets that would be
helpful
thank you representatives do that yeah
thank you mr tim
it sounds like here we don't really have
that much to do because right there's an
amendment coming
right
i i agree with the full committee right
i i agree with your position on the
issue not having the amendment but
since we have a witness who's testifying
i want to make sure we have as much
input from them as we can get so thank
you
yes thank you
anybody else would like to discuss this
section the potential it will change
we also have susan adams as the the
third speaker all right thank you go
ahead thank you mr chair i just i'm
susan adams i'm the director of state
legislative and regulatory affairs for
asha
and i did also send that language into
the full committee after the hearing
last week
and agree with judy and nicole you know
this is language that we've worked out
in maryland that we all agreed to
um you know i just it was very important
for asha to to make sure that
it read that music therapist can't treat
the communication disorder disorder
itself because that's within the scope
of practice of speech language
pathologists but they can treat an
individual with a communication disorder
i haven't reviewed the amendment myself
i don't know if anybody
oh
ms adams um the problem before was that
the speech and audio therapists
claimed that this was across the border
line into their territory do you feel
like the amendment addresses that
yes we do we we do believe the amendment
addresses that issue
interviews amendment i guess after this
at some point for the full community so
what any any more discussion on this
thank you mr chair and i'll just be
brief i think uh it's a good to hear
that all parties have come together and
agreed to an amendment
and hopefully that amendment can be
brought forward in the full committee
and we can vote on this
it's good to hear them working things
out thank you
this is an expedient to legislate i'm
just didn't expedite the left side yeah
section 6
any discussion
uh just to be clear you said you're
saying itl is that correct ideal in
section six correct thank you
uh representative roy
mr check can i speak to the motion
oh
oh sir didn't see your hand please
representative golly
yes um
i'm
not in favor of the itl motion on
section six
um
it sounds like we have an amendment
out there that would solve all the
issues that were brought forward um
in the public hearing and all these um
folks have uh come together in producing
an amendment um
i
wish we could talk about the amendment
um instead of going to ipl um
so i will vote against the unexpedient
this would just like to add that that i
agree with that i think we should give
the full committee opportunity to hear
the amendment it might change
our vote is advisory
so
i think that will be done if the
amendment is sent to the full committee
thank
so i was i believe i was asking
representative roy what his vote was
[Music]
my connection
i vote yes
i believe that's a yes
mr chairman excuse me uh
representative roy cannot vote without
having his uh video be on
which i now see
uh i vote yes thank you representative
schmidt i had a technical foxpaw thank
you
uh clerk votes yes
representative goalie
no
representative fellows
and the chair
chair votes yes
so that's what the
3-2 itl passes recommended
thank you
part 8.
i think we can do 13 after lunch like
we do have somebody who would like to
speak about this section um i didn't see
his hand up but he emailed before so um
douglas osterhout from the
department of health and human services
um just once again anybody from the
subcommittee wants to speak about this
um
yes mr chair
presenter fellows please
thank you
um
this is
this section is related to
determining if people mostly seniors
will qualify
for community care
versus
being
needing to go into a nursing home
and um
medicaid payments
are an important part of
this
process
so
um right now the people who can
make this determination by just
assessing the um
the condition and
the
like
home like personal hygiene and living
skills that the client has
the the group of people who can do that
is
uh
fairly broad and it can include
nurses but it can also include
doctors
physical therapists
almost anybody who's been giving
you know reasonable
significant care to this individual and
probably knows them the best can make
that determination
this bill
restricts it
to being just registered nurses
so
i i'm i'm not sure that
i i guess i can't speak to what was the
intent of the sponsor
but
by restricting it is cutting many people
who
who could provide a good assessment of
that person
to a registered nurse who might not even
be familiar with that person's um
situation
so i see
no upside to doing this
and only a downside because it just
you know puts
burden it makes more work for registered
nurses which we always have a shortage
of and there's no benefit of this to the
client
so
thank you mr chair um
on this section i i'm
not sure what to do um this to me should
be in the health and human services
committee it's well above beyond our
purview on edna
i know i watched a hearing yesterday
that was in resources and
it was a three-part bill that pertained
to both fish and game resources and
environment and agriculture and there
were people from
all committees attending that
to answer the questions and address the
issue and i just wish we could have the
same happen here because i think the
health and human services committee
would have
much more input and
are better to make a decision on this
section than we are
um so i i i'm asking that the chair
reached out to someone from health and
human services from the committee and uh
get some input
thank you
representative schmidt
uh thank you mr chairman i do agree with
representative goldie's suggestion that
testimony was quite clear uh in the in
the initial hearing
that this is not a question of treatment
where
the expertise the medical training and
expertise of a registered nurse uh is
appropriate and even essential
this is a question of
a uh
administrative
uh review of
um of documentation and so forth uh
having nothing to do with treatment and
and for which the
individual doing
the uh the
sorting if you will almost
is
is being overseen
uh by
a further
higher pay grade and training level
uh so i think that this
this part of the bill is not appropriate
but i think we would benefit from having
uh somebody from health and human
services
uh
you know confirm what the testimony
showed
thank you thank you representative
mcguire
yes thank you mr chair
i just resent to the full committee
a letter i got from
chair pearson of the health and human
services committee i reached out to him
after the public hearing
and he responded with a
um
an analysis of this part of the bill
and he is strongly against
removing it
he thinks it's he is strongly in favor
of removing it so that we can have the
perform these tasks and not limit it
specifically to registered nurses of
thank you i did send it uh late last
thank you i have it now and thank you
thank you
yes i'm sorry i i didn't send it earlier
but uh
i just got it yesterday
thank you
representative schmidt
yes i just want to
confer with the chair again uh
it seemed to me that that
i was unclear about what your
recommendation is
at at one point
uh
you are
the
the chair of hhs is in support of
removing this section from the bill if i
understood you correctly that is correct
you are absolutely correct
he thinks we should remove it
because it is it has a chance of harm
and no real benefit
so
and i agree with him
well the the testimony was pretty clear
that that hap requiring a
registered nurse is not necessary for
the function that's being performed at
this level uh it's not a question of
treatment where you need medical
training
so i'm glad for that clarification thank
you
i think
um
motion did you want to hear from the two
members of the public that want to speak
or are you
going to not do that i i think we're
pretty clear in the subcommittee what we
want to do here okay i just wanted to
double check thanks mr chair i make a
motion to itl take this out of the bill
i'll second that
thank you
would you like to stick to the motion or
you know
i think i think um what i said and
which uh representative maguire said
better than i did
that um we're all set
mr uh representing the dollar anything
uh i think enough has been said and i i
am uh happy with the response we got
from the chair of the health and human
so this would be
inexpedient to legislate motion on
i vote yes just for clarification though
this ipl means we would be striking this
from the bill correct
correct
then yes
and the clerk votes yes
representative goalie
yes
representative fellows
yes and the chair yes
[Music]
oops
answer
yeah but let's take a one hour break
okay thanks thank you
thank you all right i'll i'll mute the
room and when you um are ready to resume
again um please
remember to unmute
can you tell me who the two people were
that in the audience that wanted to
speak
yeah um well i can tell you it was um
doug
osterhoot from um
okay
and the other um
she's not oh granite case management um
she's that doesn't have it didn't have
her her own name just
granite case management
random case management okay
i think i know where they would be
coming from
so and i just want to clarify when we
come back at one we're going to take up
section 13.
correct
oh
i believe that's what the chair should
sell
okay and i can't unmute um the room from
here so
he maybe he could
not i don't know
he was pretty clear that he was going to
take up your
yeah okay that's what i understood too
your
i'm just going to let colleen smith know
sure that would be thank you
okay
okay so can you hear me
yes yes all right yeah i was gonna take
section 13 maybe around two o'clock just
proceed in order and
did you really want to bump it up to
one
i i would feel more comfortable with
that because you did say you were you
did say right after lunch so i i would
feel more comfortable with that because
then i you know if there's a big
discussion we just know we'll get
through it for sure
okay
hi this is jackie grota calling i just
want to make sure that you're aware that
there was an amendment that was set in
that was set in
to ols for um
an amendment to the music therapy
we discussed that we discussed that
jackie
that there's an amendment
yes
that was fully discussed
okay and then so is the committee
going to wait until they get the
amendment before they make their
to
you said we could talk about it during
the executive session but that's the
subcommittee's vote
that's the requirement yeah and that's
the recommendation okay thank you
okay yep all right let's do section 13
right after lunch at 1 o'clock
yes all right
great
[Music]
all right
welcome
back for a request of representative
fellows
we're going to discuss part 13 of sb133
this section
do you have any anybody who wants to
uh representative fellows please
um
thank you mr speaker
i i would like to say that um i did a
lot of research on this bill
and what this bill does or this section
of the bill does is it puts in statute
exceptions to the food code requirement
related to a food
protection manager
being on the premises at food food
establishments and and food
establishments
includes a lot a lot of places
includes grocery stores and convenience
stores but
i think think of it mostly in terms of
applying to restaurants
and after my research
i've come to the conclusion that we do
not need
this
section because there's no need for
there to be a statute
related to
exceptions to
the food code requirement
and the reason we don't need
we don't need it is is because there is
already a process in place
hhs has a procedure
that applies to food safety codes and
actually other
rules that they have
that
will allow
an establishment to
apply for
what what i would call a variance to the
rules they need to comply but they may
be able uh the hhs can
approve them to apply in and
comply in an alternative manner
so
we heard from aroma joes and
one of their concerns was that they have
so few employees and they also serve a
very limited
menu they only serve like coffee and
bagels
and that it would be very difficult for
them to have a person
that was qualified on the premise all of
the time and and i absolutely agree with
that
but
they do not need to put this in statute
because health and human services the
food safety bureau has um can grant them
an exception to do exactly what they
asked us to do and my understanding is
they already have
that exception
what you know what i call a variance
and
i think to put it in statute
the way it's constructed the section 13
it would help aroma joes but
it's not
really going to help um
other
other food service establishments
because the only exception they're
making is based on the number of
employees
and we have
plenty
we have places that have more than five
employees
but would legitimately qualify for a
variance an example of that would be a
place that um serves only ice cream and
ice cream related
items and
there's no reason for their any of their
employees
to know
the part of um
the what the food protection manager
needs to know about
storing
and handling raw meat because they have
absolutely none of that so they could
apply for an exception that would let
them have
10 employees if they can work out a plan
with hhs that
they can ensure that their employees
will be properly handling
ice cream and milk and that sort of um
those sort of products
so we need
something that will help all food
service establishments but at the same
time protect the public
um
one of the the way this this is
constructed right now
this would exempt
small
restaurants that serve seafood including
raw oysters and things like that as long
as they didn't have more than five
food service workers so i don't think
that's in the best interest of the
public
i think
the process that we have in place right
now in rules i think can accommodate
the concerns and the challenges that
food service establishments have and at
the same time
health and human services in the food
service bureau will be able to protect
the public
from
potential
poisonings and in that sort of thing so
my suggestion is to
completely remove this section
because everything is already in place
yes senator gaida has his hand up but i
um hello senator uh well would you
we have a question
from the subcommittee representative
yes mr chair i can uh ask after the
senator is done
all right
please
thank you members of the subcommittee
um
i'm the sponsor of this section of the
bill
and there's some
um errors in the testimony of
representative fellows this bill does
not exempt any establishment from the
rules
and the safety and
let's give a little bit of background
the hardest hit industries in this state
are the restaurant hotel industries from
the pandemic
and a very significant number
businesses
were not able to qualify for the ppp
loans and other things and so
first of all there's a labor shortage
second of all there's high turnover in
the food service industry
and so the effect the attempt of this
legislation is to protect those small
businesses that all of us have in our
towns
okay uh all it says is that instead of
what hhs has to require on-site a food
service manager
by the way the cost of training those
managers is on the business of three
hundred dollars a pop
and then a high turnover like it's
expensive
this bill just says that a manager a
food safety manager has to be part of
the business
but doesn't have to be on site and there
are a lot of small businesses including
in plymouth
where they have fewer than five five or
fewer people that actually handle the
food
okay and so this is an attempt number
one to bring relief to businesses number
two
i worked for a year and a half with hhs
which in fact backed this
bill this section of the bill in
testimony they supported it
i spoke with john williams about it
okay they supported this so i'm somewhat
concerned that this may be an attempt to
undermine what the department had
originally intended
there's no harm done by this
it helps our small businesses it
requires the same degree of safety it
permits the same levels of inspections
it just says that the small businesses
with five or fewer people that handle
food
okay don't have to have a food safety
manager on site
and the reason that's put in statute
is because
hhs did not want to deal with it
okay
their excuses that well we haven't
enforced this law because of the
pandemic and we're just kind of being
lenient but the point is
this public does not suffer
because of this law but the small
businesses that are struggling do in
fact benefit thank you mr chairman
thank you
thank you mr chair and i guess i have a
question asked as to whether
colleen smith
is available to
she she just raised her hand i'll i'll
move her over
representative
terry roy
thank you mr chair i have a question for
the senator if he's still on
um could could you please address um
representative fellow's comments for
regarding an establishment like a roman
joe's
are they currently under hss regulations
required to have a certified person on
site
and is am i correcting
understanding your testimony that by
putting this in statute they would in
the future only have to have one
as a member of the as a member of the
local
franchise
thank you
uh thank you for your question uh
they may have applied for a waiver
but annually applying for a waiver okay
is is more work for a small business
they have
several dozen outlets in the state
um and so
this statute i don't want it to sound as
though it is is exempting only them from
the requirement to have a manager on
site it's any business
the problem came to my attention uh when
constituent roma joes in fact called me
and said this is really tough to cost
it's going to cost us tens of thousands
of dollars a year
to maintain the on-site person
and that's when that was in the genesis
of this uh of this
legislation
but in no way accepts a single business
it's any small business as stated in the
statute
[Music]
representative
yes i would like to ask senator gaida
if
he thinks
an establishment
with
you know five five food service workers
that
sells
raw oysters
and
um
meat
should be
um
exempt
from from having and and having the way
it's worded in this statute
it says that they need a food service
food protection manager on staff it says
nothing about how often they have to
visit the kitchen they could be on staff
and go there twice a year
do you think that that's protecting the
safety of the public
thank you for the question
representative i think you completely
misunderstand the intent of business is
not to be irresponsible
okay and i suspect that if a small
business poisoned somebody they'd be out
of business very quickly
okay this is
this does not in any way
reduce
and the presence of a certified food
safety manager does not anyway guarantee
the safety of the food being served
this is about not eliminating the
standards not exempting businesses
from the standards or the inspections
this is about exempting businesses from
the requirement to have a person on site
the regulations remain the same the
inspections remain the same etc
thank you
representative golly
thank you mr chairman my question would
be for colleen smith i have a couple
questions for her regarding this bill so
if anyone has any questions for the
senator i'll defer until then
thank you
i just have one question in the
follow-up mr chair for the senator
follow up
thank you mr chairman dr senator for
taking my
um
real quickly just as an example let's
say i wanted to open a business tomorrow
uh selling
coffee and donuts and bagels or what
have you under the current regulation i
would have to have
someone certified on site at all times
under your proposed legislation i would
just have to have for example me be
certified but i would not have to be
there at all
and that would not exempt me from any of
the food health regulations
it just means that i wouldn't have to
have someone on staff
there at all times because
just having someone there does not
require them to do any extra safety
precautions merely that they're
certified in their is that correct
thank you
[Music]
so
colleen smith
is it
good afternoon members of the kid meet
committee for the record my name is
colleen smith i'm the administrator for
the food protection section within the
department of health and human services
and i'm happy to answer any questions
you have regarding this legislation
representative
thank you mr chair
and thank you for uh being with us today
mike mike first question and i have a
few my first question is can you tell me
it says food establishments having five
food employees can you give me what's
the definition of five foods food
employees
so there is a definition in the food
code for a food employee and that is an
employee that is
in involved in working with unpackaged
food food equipment or utensils or food
contact services so it wouldn't
necessarily be a
waiter waitress server unless they had
other responsibilities such as making
salads
or desserts or some other types of food
preparation
thank you
is there currently a
process in place
for waivers
for individuals for businesses such as
aroma joes
so we do have the ability to grant
variances to our rules there's an
application form for the variants the
the applicant would explain what rule
they're requesting a variance for and
then also put in
what measures that they would put in
place to be equally protective of public
health
follow-up
follow up
so in the circumstance of a business
such as aroma joe's that has numerous
um
shops around the state would that be one
variance it would have to be for each
individual
so each individual establishment would
be expected to apply for their own
variants
thank you follow one more follow-up
all right hello
is
i know when we had the public hearing
uh originally
that there was discussion about
something being worked on in rule making
um
and i just want to go back to that is is
that a viable option versus what we have
in front of us
as i mentioned during my testimony
during the hearing we are we were
working both tracks the legislation and
amending our rules to mirror what is set
thank you
mike zillen
[Music]
yes thank you mr chairman
this is mike sullen from aroma joe's
coffee i would like to comment um on one
of the questions that representative
goalie has just asked colleen i would
like the subcommittee to understand that
um
every city in new hampshire
does not
um have their own health inspectors so i
want the subcommittee to understand the
variance is available
through hhs for the cities that use
state health inspectors
cities and towns that have their own
health inspectors
some will recognize
new hampshire's variants some require
their own variance to this rule
and i just want to make sure that
everyone understands that that if you do
if you are operating in a town that has
its own health inspector which aroma
joe's does
i have received the same variants from
rochester new hampshire but there are
other cities um that are
unsure what they want to do with it
they're unsure of even of how to enforce
this rule and they're unsure of whether
they'll allow a variance
to happen so i
i don't want to get
i don't want to just be subject to the
rule
where that's why i really am hoping that
a statute can can arise from this so
that it's it's a state law not leave it
up to the individual districts to make
thank you yeah
representative terry roy
thank you mr chairman i have a question
for uh hss colleen if i could
um
i was wondering
um about how many variance requests they
received a year
is it only good for a year
and
are they ever denied
so i i would say um total we probably
i'd estimate 20 maybe 20 variances that
we would give a year we have the ability
within our rule to have them long to be
long a year
and
there
um there may be instances
we would
deny them
like for instance
we have often we have had uh places that
don't have running water and so we
certainly wouldn't allow a place to do
any kind of food prep or apply for a
variance without running water
that would be an example of a variance
that would be
it might be just quick follow-up um what
about this specific regulation regarding
having the personalized staff on site
so we have the requests that we've had
to this requirement have have only come
from aroma joe's up to this point but as
senator gaiden mentioned this is a very
fairly new requirement and due to the
pandemic we have been
very slow to be able to
to
i'm sorry and just i just want to put
one point of clarification is the
statute is worded it is only applicable
to
food establishments that are licensed
under dhhs the self-inspecting 15
self-inspecting communities that mr
cylin referred to as the statutes
written this this does not apply to them
it's only those that are regulated by
thank you
representative fellows
mike zillen if you have a comment on the
previous conversation please
i do thank you and thank you colleen for
that clarification i would like the
subcommittee to know though in most
instances in my experience
all of the cities and towns that
self-inspect look
look to the state to see what they're
doing so even though they would not be
subject to this same rule they they are
enforcing it and they look like
rochester for example
um
said well what is the state allowing you
to do and i said they're allowing me to
apply for a variance and he said okay
can you send me the same stuff so i
literally sent him everything that i
sent to hhs and conquered
to bob vino's office in rochester and he
allowed me
to get the same yearly variance and
that's what i'm afraid of even though
they may not be
they're not subject to it they certainly
look to conquered uh in making those
decisions
thank you representative fellows
um yes i i just wanted to ask
ms smith if if she feels comfortable in
putting into
the rsa that
that a restaurant
that
prepares raw
seafood you know serves raw seafood and
um
is she okay with those people not having
a food
food protection manager
on site when food is being prepared
because
it seems to me
you know if you're not going to do that
what's the point of having any food
answer if you
if you have an answer
sure so
i do just want to point out that we um
even if this establishment has five
employees are less on duty they do have
to have that one certified food
protection manager
on staff we do feel very strongly that
there is a strong correlation to having
that that trained educated person on
staff to be able to um
install
systems within the food establishment to
be able to run it safely when they're
not there
when that person in charge that's the
certified food protection manager is not
there there would be you know certainly
other um
enforcement tools at our disposal should
we find a particularly violative
food establishment we could remedy that
you know more training or more education
is needed based on a poor compliance
history should we find during inspection
that
um you know the that things aren't in
place in the absence of that certified
food protection manager so we feel
that having the one person on staff is
is very important and that
should the situation arise that there
would be
means where we could request that other
employees are also trained
there we go thank you
it's important to understand for example
that bed and breakfasts have been
exempted since day one
um and so
uh the small restaurant establishments
again
to emphasize they are not exempted from
the requirements for sanitation
what they're exempted from is the
requirement the very expensive
requirement in a very high turnover
environment of food service workers of
repeatedly training workers time after
time after time when they go to other
places the certification does not follow
the worker certification
is is i'm sorry it follows the worker
doesn't stay at the establishment and so
that
that food safety manager position is
important they don't just stand there
and watch
they develop a program for the business
that is reviewed by hhs for its
compliance with with the requirements
for safety of food
um and and
and that is their responsibility as a
business and hhs manager there are some
i think 8 000 businesses of this type in
the state
and so
again we're looking at a significant
number of training costs for a lot of
these small restaurants
the restaurant association supports this
bill
they understand the toughness of
business environment and these small
businesses to begin with and the extra
cost that this would bring that would
cause more harm to an already devastated
industry
this causes no no less safe
presentation of food or preparation of
food by the public again the standards
remain it's just the requirement for a
person sitting there a food service
manager could be a cook it could be a
bookkeeper it could be whomever they
don't stand there and watch
the issue is the training of the
employees and a manager that is part of
the ownership of the company as opposed
to a food service manager requirement on
site
is equally
invested in making sure that they do the
right thing and hhs has invested and
performed the inspections to ensure the
compliance with those standards and when
those compliance standards are not met
it just takes responsible action
thank you
thank you mr chair um i'm not sure
who to address this question too uh
hearing mentioned that there are several
localities
that
the state does not inspect or would not
need to comply with health and human
services would driscilla still need to
request waivers
from each of those communities even if
my excellent list
hi thank you for the question
representative um colleen if you're
still there i i certainly would value uh
your opinion on this i can speak to my
experience with the towns that i have
stores in
is yes they do allow us to apply for a
variance i in the one city that i have
five stores in rochester new hampshire
they granted me that same variance that
the state granted me in the other cities
that we operate in don't for dover for
instance in portsmouth
they
are aware of the rule
they their interpretation of the rule is
that i would that i do not um
i do not fall into a category where
they're worried about enforcing this
rule
so
that that's that's the most simple way
that i can answer that question
some municipalities that self-inspect
are requiring a variance others have not
required it
but that could change at any time i that
that's why i i'm trying to stay away
from the rules they can be changed or
interpreted by many different people
different health inspectors once they
turn over let's say you know jamie
leaves dover and a new health inspector
comes in
and wants to enforce this rule i'd have
to start the variance process with them
and who knows if that person will will
allow me
thank you representative smith
thank you mr chairman so as a member of
uh
15 years standing on the gel car i'm
wondering is there a
because the of course the rules have the
same effect as the statute they've
fully uh
have the force and effect of law the
only thing about rules is that they have
to originate from a statute the agency
can't make determinations on its own
independent of the statutory
requirements uh so my question would be
whether there is uh
for miss smith the question is uh is
there something missing in the statute
currently uh that that this bill would
uh would
would uh replace or would uh
uh
no as i mentioned before we do um we do
have
the the pieces in place to
do the rule making we've already filed
the fiscal impact statement with the lba
we're just so currently within that
section of the rule talking about
certified food protection managers we
have exempted certain facilities from
that requirement
for instance the bed and breakfasts as
senator guida had mentioned earlier the
retail stores without food preparation
such as a rite aid a cumberland farms a
um
a dollar general that they are not
currently
required to have that certified food
protection manager and so we would be
looking just to expand that section of
the rule and again it mirrors the our
proposed language mirrors that is what's
set forth in the statute
follow-up
follow up
okay so in other words you're going to
be coming before the jail car
uh with a a proposed rule change
which clearly you can't do unless it's
based on a statute as i said earlier uh
so you're in the process of developing
those rules as we speak
yes that's correct
okay and and that follow up again mr
chairman so that that the is uh it's not
dependent on the whether this statute
this bill
you couldn't be at developing a rule
based on a perspective statute you can
only base it on an existing statute so
my question is uh for you know for the
those who are not familiar with the gel
card process
so you're telling me that that you're
currently developing a rule based on
existing statutes that would resolve
this issue
that is correct
thank you
do you have anybody
members of else
subcommittee uh representative fellows
um yes for for miss um
smith
so
what sort of criteria
like i know that already
bed and breakfasts and the places you
talked about that just basic in dollar
general that just have basically that
prac that packaged food
they're
exempt
now and there's no reason that they
would not
be exempt
from the food protection
protection manager also
but
isn't the criteria that
those places ended up on that exemption
list didn't that don't doesn't that have
to do with the safety
related to the food items that they're
serving and that the pro the possibility
of those
being
contaminated and making somebody sick is
extremely low
and
isn't
an exemption that's based on the number
of workers
very different from
that criteria
yes
please
sure sure so currently the those types
of establishments that i mentioned that
have no food preparation so they're
exempt from the certified food
protection
manager requirement altogether
um you know as the language and the
proposed
bill
mentions and also in in our rule they
would those the types of establishments
that would have the
exemptions is just for the presence at
all hours of operation they still are
going to need to have that certified
food protection manager on staff but in
these certain instances where
it's only reheating food or handling
ready-to-eat food or the instances of
the the five employees are or fewer they
have to have that person on on staff
still
yeah so on staff
tell me how often they have to be well
you will say how often they have to be
in the establishment because on staff
especially if you're dealing with a
bigger company that has multiple sites
that could be one person
on staff
apparently in
in the head office
doing
accounting
might be certified and that person
how often do they have to go and visit
the kitchens that we're talking about
that we're trying to make sure are
operating safely
we we didn't put that level of
specificity on the on staff as far as
having an in
a
facetime or an actual um in
establishment presence
um
you know however the expectation would
be is that they
they would have
that presence to be able to
make sure
uh staff were were trained
appropriately according to their duties
having at least um that
one um person that has gone through the
training and educated in food safety on
on their employee
roster
any more discussion
on part 13
right senator guida please
thank you mr chairman
um
at the apparent failure to understand
the rigors of doing business
um and those that are opposed to moving
the certification evaporates when the
employee leaves the business not even
transferable to the next business that
incurs a cost on any subsequent business
that that person might need to be worked
in okay and once again this does in no
way diminish
the safety
requirements
the degree of inspections the number of
inspections
it puts the responsibility for running
the business on the business and the
responsibility for responsibly running
the business on a very small business in
a segment of our end of our of our
state's economy that has been devastated
okay and
again
you have to come to grits with a
fundamental question
okay who is most qualified to run that
business
who wants that business to succeed
and who's interested in levying further
unnecessary government regulations and
restrictions and costs on the businesses
that are struggling as we speak
that's fundamentally what's at stake
here this bill causes no harm whatsoever
this bill in fact helps small businesses
that are complying will continue to
comply because if they fail to comply
the 8 000 food businesses or however
many of those are exempted
by this statute
okay from having an on-site manager not
exempted from the standards okay this
helps those businesses including
businesses in plymouth including
businesses in warren including
businesses all over the state
people that are struggling that didn't
qualify for the ppp loans or the main
street loans
okay this is about keeping our economy
strong not sacrificing in any way
the quality of food produced the safety
of the production
or the responsibility of the owners of
the businesses to make sure that their
safety programs are in place
and of course
reinforced with the inspections by the
department of health and human services
thank you
representative fellows did you have a
comment
oh that's fine
okay please i would like to say that my
parents owned a business
and my family owned restaurant
businesses
and i have worked in many restaurants
i understand the struggle
of small businesses
and i also understand the safety issues
of restaurants
and restaurants when they're inspected
that happens maybe once a year maybe it
may be in those larger cities it's more
than once a year but generally once a
year
and
that is not very good protection for the
public
if
for somebody to show up once a year is
very
low level of protecting the public and
illnesses
and
and i
i've i three years ago i had i was
served in a restaurant a um
serving of steamed mussels that included
two that were not open
and two that were cracked which is
absolutely not within the food service
standards and it's very disturbing that
that would even happen but a once once a
year inspection is not going to
address that issue
so
there's a very big value for having this
requirement
to have
people that are
that are certified as food protection
managers
in the kitchen
in health and human services and the
local
inspectors have an opportunity to grant
appropriate waivers and i would hope
that their
waivers are based on the level of threat
of the food that's being served and not
on how many people are there
so i'm just concerned about public
safety and i'm
very
um disappointed that senator geider
doesn't seem to be concerned much about
that at all
all right thank you
senator
the
requirements
remain in place
the responsibility for the business
whether or not there's a food site
manager on site
okay and by the way less than 500
incidents a year out of 8 000
restaurants in the state
okay
so
once again it's the question of more
regulations on business that are not
necessary
because the current standards serve just
fine they have up until this point
in fact the rules that are brought in by
hhs are not even federally mandated
they're suggested
right
so the question again before you is
in passing this legislation
you are neither reducing
for the public
nor
the diligence required of the business
you are in fact reducing
the costs to the business
and the onus on the business of
continuing to comply with paperwork year
after year
continue to deal with the high turnover
rate
and and for which the certification
disappears once an employee leaves
we are building a more building a bigger
bureaucracy
that does nothing to increase the safety
of the establishments
but in fact levy's considerable costs
and paperwork on them
and is unnecessary
this bill does not exempt anyone from
any requirements how many times we have
to say that
and in food service management
establishments where the food service
manager safety managers on site
they cannot possibly watch every food
service
serving portion
and and delivery
they're there in a management capacity
for a safety program they do their own
inspections
they don't sit behind the desk somewhere
and not because they care about the
business respect the business owners
allow them the responsibility which has
produced no problems this far without
this regulation
so we don't need it at this point for
those small businesses the number of
employees once again does not exempt
them from the standards it just says
you're small enough that we respect the
costs that this brings okay and we
understand that you are going to be
responsible because in the business
world when people get sick in the food
business it soon goes away
you need to respect the owners of the
business government does its job this is
unnecessary uh regulation that would
require that food service managers
presence on site thank you mr chairman
thank you senator
all right
um
if
we're done discussing it i'd like to
to recommend this part
uh otp
second
i think there's a lot of confusion
between towns and um
the small shops do not really deserve to
be forced into
begging
for an exception every time day to day
even could you speak up a little louder
yes yes um
yeah i'm just saying that the small shop
should not be forced into building for
this exception every time
uh department rules change and i would
like to move this determination into
statutes the regulation of
food protection managers that's why i'm
making this motion thank you
i would um
sorry i would uh second what you said i
think that
this regulation
at this point i have heard no evidence
why it's necessary
it's an undue burden on small businesses
and there does seem to be some confusion
about requirements between localities
and the state
and seeing as the voluntarily on the
federal portion
i just don't see especially right now
why we should be putting more
uh weight on small businesses trying to
survive so high second year motion after
so representative fellows
um yes i would just like to speak to
your motion
and
if it or ought to pass i see issues with
it related to definitions
we don't have a definition of
food employees
so
this is in statute there's no way
somebody would be able to
know if that covered the wait staff or
or
not
and
also the requirement to have
food protection manager on staff
i believe also needs some kind of
clarification
because staff where staff at that
establishment and just something that
says something about how often they
actually go there just to so that you
they're not on staff and
in they
never
you know they visit twice a year
because
the food service the inspectors that go
need some kind of standard to know if
they're they're doing what
the intent is for those
um food protection managers to do which
is be training those staff that work
there to adhere to the food
code
thank you um
i yeah
all right i would love senator to
provide some guidance on that
good questions senator please
thank you
in fact every every term in that
legislation is defined
and again
everything that needs to be done has
been done
uh the
um
the the
specious requirement
that a food service manager must appear
so many times once again delves into
over-regulating businesses and again i
say that
business people do not want to fail
they invest their life savings
i'm sorry yes i'm sorry senator right
we're
we're in the voting mode that is correct
yeah if
if you had an answer for representative
fellows i guess question or maybe it's
better addressed in the full committee
if
or you and her may discuss amendments
because we're not um amending it today
in any way
we do it in the full committee if
there's anything
so
let's
let's proceed with the voting
so as i understand it the motion is
about to pass and
yes
representative fellows
no
and the chair
thank you everybody we're going back to
temporary life center of
certain licensed nursing is six systems
[Music]
do we have anybody interested in
um broderick
sure he's on his way
so is this nine
good afternoon members of the
subcommittee
um so i
i i have just one short um piece to add
here and um lindsay courtney actually it
looks like she's still on but i think
she had to leave my executive director
oh
hold on let me let me begin i'm tom
broderick i'm legal counsel for the
office of professional licensure and
certification um and so the board of
nursing is under our umbrella um
we really just had one main concern we
wanted to bring to the subcommittee's
attention um
regarding the cms requirements um
so
we are suggesting let me just pull up
the email
to comply with the center for medicaid
and medicare medicare and medicaid
services
we may need to add a
section that
states that lnas that have completed
those 100 hours are
deemed to have taken a board approved
course i believe that this will
this is necessary to comply with uh the
requirements for medicare
um
would you if you have text would you
send it to the full committee please
representative
fellows
yes i just for mr broderick i'm just
wondering if you can
paragraph two
about
it says not withstanding any provision
of law to the contrary the state
approved training program
for licensed nurses nursing assistants
shall take into account training and
experience required
you know
for that i'm i'm a little confused
because
the training programs
when i looked up the statute i think i
was looking
um
i think i was looking at nursing board
rules
the
the training programs
are one option
for
somebody to get certified and those
programs are like the programs offered
at the
at the community colleges
that require something like
40 hours of classroom time and
60 hours of clinical
and the other option for
um
lnas is
kind of like a apprenticeship like on
the job
two hours 200 hours
so those are the two options and i just
don't state approved training program i
i'm broderick uh may i defer to my
executive director lindsay courtney um i
she's a little more involved in the the
board of nursing
piece
all right lindsay courtney
thank you mr chairman uh for the record
lindsay courtney office of professional
licensure and certification
so um there really is one way um to
obtain licensure status as an lna
um it's through attending a board
approved education program that consists
of a hundred hours um and the reason for
that is even though that the the state
of new hampshire can regulate nurses and
nursing assistants and basically however
um
you know format they choose
there are um cms regulations that limit
the ability for
um long-term care long-term care
facilities to be reimbursed um to those
individuals who have um obtained
specific training and the specific
training is that it has to be approved
basically by a board or a state-approved
training program so
um essentially all uh lnas have to go
through a state-approved training
program
we have a number of
lna programs um some at community
colleges so you know we partner with um
some private entities as well in order
to prove that the the concern that i
have with this particular statutory
provision is twofold it's it's somewhat
confusing it the it seems to um i think
the intent is to allow those temporary
health partners to transition to
licensure
on just by completing 100 hours of
experience
um if that's the case then there needs
to be some language in there as attorney
broderick mentioned
such that they shall have been deemed to
complete uh a board-approved program
because otherwise they won't be eligible
um for reimbursement or the facilities
for which they work the second provision
of this is somewhat confusing because it
essentially directs
the um
training programs to take into
consideration previous work performed
um
those programs
they can develop their own curriculum
subject to board of nursing regulations
so i guess it's not clear to me um
to what extent and how they would take
that into consideration so i think that
that needs um you know
further clarification
i don't know if that answers your
question represented
well basically you're saying you're
confused by the same thing that i was
confused by okay so
so
what do you think is the path forward i
mean
do you feel comfortable with just saying
we'll we'll just
consider those 100 hours
to be
this the same as
a state-approved
sound really great
i don't think they're the same i can
tell you what the discussion was at the
time that the emergency order was
issued
the emergency order itself was the
result of a lot of collaboration the
board of nursing and the agency were
particularly concerned about the
original idea and proposition which was
to allow individuals with eight hours of
a webinar experience to function as an
lna because we didn't think that was
appropriate in order to protect the
public
the um collaboration and the compromise
was that these individuals could assist
lnas and obtain experience essentially
like making beds and that sort of thing
um it's difficult to assess you know the
levels of experience that they obtained
and in order to assess the
qualifications so
what the stakeholders concluded was that
the board of nursing would work with the
programs themselves um in order to
develop a situation and approval where
where the schools could take into
consideration prior experience perhaps
less than the amount of hours required
or
allow them to utilize prior experience
um to
constitute 60 hours of their clinical
work because presently 40 hours of those
have to be in person learning which is
not represented here in the statute so
so what what is the status of that
discussion yeah
we have not had um uh in a program
petition the board of nursing at this
point in time in order to modify program
approval to take into consideration
these temporary health partners
okay thank you
golly you mr chair and i just voiced the
same concerns um
as representative fellows and
um as i look at this this is
only for those
temporary health partners who have um
completed this prior to uh april of this
year um
so it's it's
just for a few individuals um that
worked um
during the pandemic but i'm not sure
the term temporary health partner um
i think we just continue to look at
nursing homes cannot get the help they
need in the lnas because they don't pay
enough and i think by creating this
temporary health partner we've um even
produced lower wages um in the
healthcare field and i think it's going
to be more difficult to find uh
replacements
for the for those uh positions um so i'm
i think there's some issues with this
section
i'm willing to hear a little more about
it but um
as of right now i'm not sure about
uh voting on it as is
thank you thank you representative
fellows
um yes i i don't even know
who to tell
this to but what what i would like to
see in place of this is something that
says like those
temporary health
partners can for free
take the course
take take the course at the community
college or with whomever wants to offer
it to them and that the state pays their
tuition and pays for their books and
pays for the the exam fee for them so
that it doesn't cost them anything but
then we'll know that there that they
meet all the standards for
that um position
that's what i'd like to see i don't
think we can just i don't know if we can
stick that in the billing
not in the subcommittee but right
yeah thank you
yes yes
representative
i would liken this to a battlefield
promotion and i think this
representative goalie struck right on it
that it's a very few people within a
very constrained period of time that are
getting this so
i mean i think you know they didn't go
to west point but they're getting a
thank you
any
any videos yep
yeah
and the fellas
yeah we're so we're still not addressing
the the medicaid
issues see cms i guess because
we're not addressing the cms issue
because if we don't do something
different with what we have here
then those people
if they go to work in a nursing home the
nursing home won't be able to get the
medicaid
payments for those positions so i i
think we we absolutely can't just pass
it the way it is we have to do
either
take it out or
which which lines are we talking about
i don't see that but yes please
thank you the only thing i was going to
say is to representative fellows points
and there are um reimbursement programs
that were recently expanded it used to
only be reimbursement directly to
the um applicant
attending the program but now we
actually reimburse um in conjunction
with cms and dhhs
the programs themselves that it can
sponsor individuals to go through so for
moat for many people if not most people
that you know they do have eligibility
for reimbursement the problem is just
finding bodies willing to take the
program
does it cover all the costs
the
fees and the books and everything
i'm gonna i i would like to get back to
you on the specifics of that i do know
that we in the office do verify
attendance um so that checks go out and
i it's somewhere in the couple thousand
dollar range but i can give you
thank you mr chair just uh one quick
question and it may also
uh could be fixed in an amendment
portion but uh looking at this seeing
that um
all of this will take place to those um
who are in uh by april 1st of 2021
um
that this says it takes effect 60 days
couldn't we just amend that to be uh
take effect upon passage um i don't know
why we need to wait 60 days if these
folks have already done their hours and
completed everything
i agree and maybe miss courtney could
answer whether they could do it upon
passage
i would like that too but yes please
miss court
i don't see any problems with it
legal problems with it being effective
upon passage
i provided that you make those changes
regarding the reimbursement
issues and tom and i can get you some
language if if that would be helpful
thank you mr chairman i just have a
question um we're talking about this
reimbursement um
i'd like to know what the potential cost
of that would be and
it does uh have that in their budget
because
there's been no money appropriated for
thank you
probably miss courtney again
um since you know most about the money
where is it coming from
so for the most part it comes um we
it comes from dhhs as part of the cms
reimbursement so it's tied into cms
reimbursement to the state
i'd have to get back to you with
specifics um
but it's not coming from state general
follow-up
but if we expanded it to cover
everything representative fellow
suggested books fees
and all this for these these folks that
the
this statute would contemplate would
i i think we'd have to look into that
close you know
closely i don't know that dhhs
i think we first need to determine
exactly what the expenses are um i
believe it's all expenses but i think we
need to determine what the expenses are
and then secondly what you know what
they can do for reimbursement
um we are reimbursing at a pretty good
rate
um
but
i don't know what's available from a cms
perspective most likely it would have to
be you know the agency itself would have
to fund
some of that i assume
so i i had in mind an amendment of my
own so the 60-day passage is very yeah i
would like to take that out in full
committee and make it up on passage i
also was looking to remove the april
first date
completely
because that's past and because we're
still on the pandemic battlefield
so um
since we need more bodies on the
battlefield
i would like
who is able to help
and go through this program
to be there
this way we'll tie
the status of temporary health partner
to the end of the emergency order 42 or
the lifting of the
restrictions
so my proposal proposed amendment for
the full committee will be to remove
if if there's no if there's no more
i'll make another motion of otp to
recommend this part
with further amendments potentially
coming
i'll second
um
representative roy how do you vote
votes yes
yes
representative fellows
thank you a 500 past unanimous
relative to the location of licensure
for licensed emergency medical service
units and emergency medical service
vehicles
would anybody
no
i think i have co-sponsors here in the
chief for manelo please
good good afternoon again um i i could
explain a little bit about the bill if
you guys what guys and guys would like
um
excuse me
essentially what we're we're trying to
do is
um
change language to be more in line with
other healthcare professions um and give
the commissioner the ability to
um
change the wording from shallow to may
issue
and then the second piece of it is add
excuse me to add
a letter of concern as a potential uh uh
finding as opposed to the only ability
he has now is revocation or suspension
of a license
thank you
certainly not gonna answer any questions
sir
any discussion on this
so
is it the fellas
yeah
thank you um i just does this apply to
this doesn't apply to
emts is that correct it applies to
certainly so um it applies to all those
that we license so it would be licensed
ems units uh any infractions on vehicles
okay
and just one follow-up
yeah that the
term
letter of concern is that um
a description that you see in other
statutes
or
is that unique is going to be a unique
thing
so um i couldn't point you in a
direction but it is something we've seen
in other statutes um in the in the
reason why if i could just explain
briefly um there you know the benefit of
the letter of concern is right now if in
fact there's a finding
that does not substantiate a an action
uh in the future so revocation or
suspension of a license the only
mechanism that the commissioner has
would be to suspend or
revoke a license in the past and and
and that's what we we've used uh this
would give another you know mechanism
another tool to say all right there's a
letter of concern in the file um
as opposed to actually take that action
representative roy
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question could you explain the
necessity to change um
between a
shell issue and a may issue please
that may be the question to the chief
certainly
um so
this this was in line with other
language so the um
for nursing and for physicians uh and
and so we thought it would be a good
opportunity at this point to get in line
with the other uh boards as far as those
that discipline providers uh in in
healthcare workers
uh
i know there was some question in
in the public hearing where you know
could there be a case where the the
commissioner uh you know chose to not uh
issue and issue a uh some sort of action
when when an investigation found the
necessity for that um and i don't think
that that this would be the case it's
just uh providing an an option
uh i guess an example would be used is
that um
you know we we encourage local medical
directors uh and local agencies to
to to first deal with issues as they
they um
they avail themselves uh and then it
escalates to a state level so there
there could be a case where a a local um
uh unit and the medical director through
the medical resource hospital agreement
had put somebody on we'll say a
disciplinary action and
restrict their ability to
to practice uh aside from under a mentor
or some sort of preceptor and in the
course of the investigation
uh we may have found a finding but in
that duration of time they've already
remedied the situation um and so at that
point you know they've already kind of
met a penalty uh and it's been
appropriately mitigated in the same
manner that we would with we'll say a
letter of concern and some sort of
educational requirements
um you know in in in a investigation and
discipline for that so
uh you know that would be the only time
that i would say that we may not at that
time issue some sort of uh
or the commissioner may choose not to
issue a revocation suspension or a
letter of concern
uh where there's already been a
punishment at the local level or not a
punishment but a corrective action they
should say you're stand corrected
thank you
all right um
if there are no more
discussion
make a motion to otp
deception
do you recommend it
second
uh representative roy how do you vote on
otp
yes
representative goalie
representative fellows
yes and the chair
50 section 10
all right
friendship
relative to schools for barbarian
does anybody who is present want to
speak about it
uh
um
please unmute
representative mcguire yes thank you mr
chair
i was asked to look into
how this fit with house bill
575 which we passed earlier this year
the
most of it is totally unrelated
but
the
one difference that
uh
that is
that matters is in the last paragraph of
this section
where
um
house bill 575
talks about
um
this is on rsa 313
dash a colon 24
it's on page 50 line 5.
to
issue an apprentice certificate to any
student receiving instruction within a
licensed school or shop to learn
barbering cosmetology aesthetics or
manicuring
the
house bill 575
says that it within a licensed school
and or shop
so that individuals can
get
some training in a shop and some
um
within a shop
and
that is the house position
so i would i had i would like to
recommend that we amend
the word or to and or which will mean
that there is no conflict with
house bill 575. i've given the senate an
amendment to 575 that says if this
passes
their section
uh roman 1 would not apply
because this is a more
um more thorough amendment
and it
the the
the and or is the only difference that
would make a difference
i hope that's clear if not i'll answer
questions
all right um
there's no more discussion i'd like to
make a motion to recommend section 11 to
otp
mr chair with that change
if you if
oh yes yes with the potential amendment
upcoming
representative roy
seconded
it's not mr clerk just overall
so the motion is otpa with amendment
which we don't yet have but uh
representative roy
yes
uh
clerk votes yes
yes
representative fellows
and the chair
the chair holds this so that would be
5-0
yes
section 11.
did you do section 12 oh i'm sorry i'm
so sorry
[Music]
called just telemedicine for
psychologists
i don't know oh we have something
present
indeed yes sorry he's on his
i don't either
he's on the edge
he's on
um
if i unintentionally
delete it i i prom oh here he is
there we go it just took the long route
thank you mr chairman members of the
subcommittee for the record my name is
john dejoy and i'm here representing the
new hampshire psychological association
i have to say my heart sank when you
were just about to close the meeting
before section 12. so thank you very
much
um this will be this will be brief as i
said i'm representing the psychologists
and
the psychologists just want to remind
the subcommittee of an existing issue
that you heard about at the hearing and
that is in regards to rsa 329 d
which is the scipact
that is currently in our statute
obviously and
is in fact the controlling statute on
telehealth services
where other state
providers live in siteback states
so to avoid confusion our request is is
just adding the 329d language as an
exemption
in the language before you
and i have
there's i believe two places that that
we would recommend that be done i have
that language drawn up that i would be
happy to send to the committee
subcommittee excuse me uh you know the
full committee for that full community
yes so you were in support of this
section
but you have uh some changes
yeah we're we're fine with this section
because every state in the united states
is not cypack so there may be some
psychologists who would benefit from
this but scipac clinicians would already
be covered by this
here please send
your changes or amendments
to the full committee
sure i'm happy to mr chair do we know uh
what's the timeliness of this do we know
when this is going to be exact by the
committee
um
representative mcguire
i guess thank you we are going to have a
work session on it
next tuesday okay but even if we reach
full agreement on every section we will
not
be able to vote on it for a week
because we need to get a complete
amendment so if i make sure you have my
language by monday that should be enough
time
yes okay great thank you
thank you
good afternoon again and for the record
uh tom broderick uh legal counsel the
office of professional licensure and
certification um
i
had testified to this on the uh the full
committee hearing i don't want to
rehash everything in general oplc is
neutral on this
i had brought up a couple points that
i'm not sure oplc thinks oplc thinks
it's necessary
um anyone that prac that has a new
hampshire license may practice through
telehealth already and
um
i'm not sure why we need a separate
license for
a
someone coming in from the state out of
state to do telehealth as someone
licensed here
the standard of care really should be
the same no matter what
um
so i'm not sure why we have sort of
lesser standards
for this telepass um as we do for our
full licensure
um
yeah i think that's about it
thank you mr chair and i i was going to
um
raise my concerns the same as mr
broderick on that um i remember that
during the testimony
as to whether or not this
truly is needed or
we are already pretty much covered under
other areas
one more quick
uh for mr broderick is that does that
mean
those coming
in
doing telehealth from out of state will
be paying an additional fee is that what
i heard you say
um
for this the telepaths the proposed
telepaths
yes so my understanding and i should say
this was drafted by the board of
psychologists who is a board under
oplc's umbrella um my understanding is
it would be a
they would be charged a
fee to come in
under their telepaths
license
they would not need to also get a new
hampshire license so
they someone in louisiana as we talked
about
for another
bill
rather than getting a new hampshire
license to be able to serve remotely
through telehealth someone here in new
hampshire they could get a telehealth
license
follow up
so
this would address somewhat
similar to my concerns when we did talk
about
compacts and having compacts and people
coming in
we have additional licensees working in
state not paying license fees here in
new hampshire for the services they're
providing but paying to a home state
this
would somewhat alleviate my concerns by
charging those that are licensed out of
state
paying somewhat to a board
a fee to practice you
i mean my understanding yes
they under this telehealth
program they would be paying a fee to
the state of new hampshire it would be
less than we'd be charging our our full
applicants i think um
dr warner had testified to that so if we
made each other we right now by statute
we are charging for a new hampshire
license 300
um i think she had thought this would be
more along the lines of 90 so we'd be
charging less to someone
coming into our state remotely from out
of state
to recommend it to the full committee
and otpa because there may be an
amendment coming
mr chair i see miss courtney raising our
hands
thank you for the record lindsey
courtney executive director office of
professional licensure um
i just wanted to express
that i have some concerns regarding this
bill i do not believe it's necessary
i
appreciate the objective which is to
make it easier for people to obtain a
license in new hampshire
but i don't think that this bill is the
way to approach it so presently right
now anybody can provide tele health
telepsychology services with a
psychology license
the issue is and i think that the board
has recognized it is that people have
difficulties with getting a license
but for my
my observation the reason they have
difficulty getting a license is because
the actual rules are onerous not the
statutory requirements
i think that the best uh way to deal
with this issue is to actually have the
board
amend its rules to make it easier for
people to obtain a license rather than
create additional licensing categories
i do want to note that the standard of
care how you provide care to people has
to be the same regardless of the
platform that it's delivered
so it doesn't make sense that somebody
receiving telehealth services
um
with the same standard of care
would you know
that somebody providing those services
would not have to jump through the same
hoops as somebody who provides in-person
visits because everything else is the
same other than the platform um through
which these services are delivered i
just think that the administrative
burdens um regarding processing
additional licenses from the office of
professional licensure
really don't warrant the additional
license uh as required i think the board
just needs to do its work and and then
thank you mr chairman so miss courtney
do you have any question whether the
board has the statutory authority
to uh to grant this
under its current statute
they do um
so they do have the authority so right
now with a psychology license you can
provide telehealth services to anybody
physically located in new hampshire
um with a with a regular psychology
license you can also provide those
services in person
whether you need a license um is based
on where the patient is physically
located so so the a person with a
regular psychology license can certainly
provide telehealth services and i will
note uh for interest that 67 percent of
individuals with an active license in
new hampshire providing psychology
services have an emergency license
and i think that that's pretty telling
about how easy it is to obtain an
existing psychology license but i don't
think the answer is to create a new
licensing category i think it's to
modify our existing our existing
structures to align with what the board
thinks is appropriate for telehealth
uh follow-up follow-up
um okay so uh
one of the questions that i that i was
discussing recently was you know uh with
regard to when telehealth or
is is uh involved uh where is the
service service being provided i mean
obviously the provider is someplace
if the
if the patient call them the patient is
someplace else
um
has it been adjudicated it seems to me
like the service is being provided where
the patient is
regardless of where the
the doctor is the patient getting the
service that's where it's being provided
but has that been adjudicated
to your knowledge
not in new hampshire that i'm aware of
so but generally speaking most states
have taken that position other courts
have taken that position um the state of
new hampshire i would assume has taken
that position by virtue of the fact that
when the state of um emergency was
enacted and everybody had to go to a
telehealth platform those people who
those providers that were located
outside of state suddenly needed a new
hampshire license to continue to treat
their patients that's the general rule
with telemedicine
is that the practice is deemed to occur
where the patient is physically located
right that that certainly would be my
logical assumption
but but
the the question is not whether you and
i agree about that the question is
whether the courts uh and and so
to the degree that you uh think it's
been done some places just not
necessarily here
that's the answer
okay thank you
representative roy
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
i'm not sure if this is germane to this
or not but i've noticed there's a lot of
apps popping up
where you can get psychological services
online through an app
through some type of video conference
thing with um psychologists from all
over the country how does new hampshire
handle that
so if if um
we would handle it the same way we
handle any sort of practice if if
they're providing services
and there are patients located in new
hampshire physically located in new
hampshire they would have to have a
license
if um they don't have a license
um then our most of our regulatory
boards including the board of psychology
do not have jurisdiction over that
matter if we were to get wind of it
however we would refer that over to the
uh consumer protection bureau of the
department of justice so that they could
take appropriate action
thank you
all right um
back to the motion i would like to
with potential amendments coming in the
full committee
i i can't hear you
oh yeah
seconded by representative roy
um
i i think this
this is a good bill it actually helped
consumers and we're talking about the
expediency when they need the services
if they travel between states come and
go out
this will help them in an expedient
manner
because they can still reach their
doctor when they're visiting when
they're on vacation or they're going
elsewhere
that's why i'm making the motion
representative roy
i i would check out what you say
and
thank you mr chair and i'm going to uh
voting against that motion um
i think we heard in testimony that uh
telemedicine can already take place
without this
um
this is just new hampshire that's going
to be collecting its own fee i think
this bill this section of the bill uh
the language in here needs more work um
i would rather see it removed
um from the omnibus bill and uh brought
back is another piece of legislation
um next year that could be really worked
on by the committee to get a good
product i don't think it's ready for
prime time and i don't think we should
be passing something that isn't ready
for prime time quite yet and needs a
little bit of work so i'll vote against
it and hope that um i don't see a dire
need for it to come out um right now um
i think we could do some work on it if
it came back next year so i'll be voting
against motion
yes
overall so
the motion is otp
one part 12 representative roy
yes
that would be passing
3-2
representative schmidt
did you
i just i waited till you're done with
the voting yeah
yeah so i just want to suggest that if
representative goldie uh
wants something better brought back next
thing obviously uh would depend on
whether this passes or not but to the
degree that we voted to retain
the bill uh
then we wouldn't have to fight the thing
that the possibility that
that the uh
bill in the second term
would be blocked by the fact that we
voted at itl
this time around
so i just want to suggest that to him
that maybe
the motion we would want if that's where
the way
the way the committee wants to go
is that we would retain it and let it
and work on it and so forth
just a thought
yeah we've got we've still got time
until the full community i know i i just
wanted to run that past the subcommittee
because
obviously there's some
uh some issue here
that we we may want to further consider
mr chair if we if i might
representative goalie
i don't think there is the ability to
retain certain sections of this it's
either amended
one way up or down and that's the only
way we can do it is to pull out sections
put sections in we can't retain certain
sections it's a bill as a whole it's an
omnibus bill
yes okay
yeah
yep
right quite well taken
uh yes thank you mr chair i was going to
agree entirely with representative
goalie it's in or out
we can't retain a portion of a bill
but
[Music]
and in fact having it removed from from
an omnibus would not invalidate it for
coming in next year as a separate bill
in any event
that's true for all of the sections
right
thanks for pointing that out joe
um i think we're done with this session
yes everybody yes pam
yes since
absolutely all right everybody go back
to the beach
we got the beach to go to thank you very
much
you can't see terry's pina colada